WE WILL AT THE END IS GOOD
MORNING WILL BEGIN TODAY'S.
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
EDUCATION FINANCE.
ON HIGHER EDUCATION PROPOSALS
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION
FIRST LET'S CALL THE ROLL.
MCCARTY HERE.
MEDINA HERE.
O'DONNELL.
VOEPEL.
QUORUM IS ESTABLISHED.
OKAY SO TODAY 粒
THE PROPOSALS FROM. THE
GOVERNOR.
WILL BE TAKING THE ACTIONS
TODAY THAT WOULD BE.
LATER.
NEXT WEEK ACTUALLY.
SO WITH THAT WE WILL BEGIN WITH
ISSUE NUMBER ONE WITH OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THE PROPOSED
REVISIONS TO THE ONLINE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PROPOSAL
OKAY PLEASE BEGIN. A GOOD
MORNING RATES THAT WOULD KEY SAT
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
I HAD THE ME REVISION MAKE
SEVERAL CLARIFICATIONS AND
CHANGES TO THE ONLINE COLLEGE
PROPOSAL IN RESPONSE TO A
FEEDBACK THAT WE'VE RECEIVED SO
ALL FOCUS MY REMARKS ON THE
VARIOUS CHANGES.
THE MAYOR MEASURE PROPOSES
SEVERAL AYE CHANGES RELATED TO
THE COLLEGE'S GOVERNANCE AND
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING. OUT WE'VE
HEARD A LOT OF CONCERNS ABOUT
THAT UP PROCESS FOR COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING.
SO THE MAY REVISION TRAILER
BILL ENSURES THAT FACULTY AND
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES OF THE
COLLEGE WOULD BE REPRESENTED FOR
PURPOSES OF A COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING. AND TO ACCOMPLISH
THIS THE ONLY COLLEGE FOR
PARTNER WITH AN EXISTING
DISTRICT OUT FOR THE PURPOSES OF
ESTABLISHING THAT AGREEMENT.
INSTEAD OF CREATING A NEW
INDEPENDENT BOARD UNDER ANY
DISTRICT UNDER THE MAYOR VISION
PROPOSAL THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS
WOULD SERVE AS THE GOVERNING
BOARD OF THE ONLINE COLLEGE. TE
CHANCELLOR AND THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS WHICH IS THE PRESIDENT
OF THE ONLY COLLEGE AND THE
COLLEGE'S PRESIDENT'S WOULD
MANAGE AND CONTROL THE
OPERATIONS OF THE COLLEGE.
I HAD THE PRESIDENT OF THE
COLLEGE WOULD ALSO ESTABLISH AN
ADVISORY COUNCIL WHICH WOULD
INCLUDE REPRESENTATIVES FROM
LOCAL TRUSTEES AND EMPLOYEES OF
THE COLLEGE TO ADVISE HIM OR HER
ON ISSUES RELATED TO THE
COLLEGE.
THE MAYOR VISION ALSO. INCLUDES
PROVISIONS RELATED TO STUDENT
OUTCOMES AND STUDENT PROTECTIONS
THIS INCLUDES REQUIRING THE
COLLEGE TO PROVIDE A
COMPREHENSIVE REPORT IN ITS
THIRD YEAR OPERATION ON STUDENT
OUTCOMES. INCLUDING STUDENT
EMPLOYMENT EARNING GAINS AFTER
COMPLETION OF PROGRAMS AND OTHER
SUCCESS METRICS IDENTIFIED BY
THE BY THE RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT UNIT OF THE COLLEGE.
AS WELL AS A DESCRIPTION OF THE
COLLEGES PROGRESS ARE REACHING
WORKING ADULTS.
ADDITIONALLY THE COLLEGE WOULD
BE REQUIRED TO SHARE PROMISING
PRACTICES AND PROCESS HE'S WITH
THE OTHER COMMUNICATIVE DRESS.
AND THE MAYOR VISION ALSO ADDS
PROVISIONS TO REQUIRE THE
COLLEGE TO COMPLY WITH
DISABILITY AND ACCESSIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS TO DEVELOP A
PROCESS FOR RECORDING AND
ADDRESSING COMPLAINTS AND
REPORTING BACK. ON COMPLAINTS
WITH THESE REQUIREMENTS.
IN RESPONSE TO CONCERNS ABOUT
ACCREDITATION THE MAYOR REVISION
CLARIFIES THAT THE PRESIDENT OF
THE ONLY COLLEGE WOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR COMMAND SEEM BE.
ACCREDITATION PROCESS
IMMEDIATELY UPON ENROLLMENT OF.
BECAUSE THE COLLEGE'S FIRST
COHORT OF STUDENTS.
WE'VE HEARD CONCERNS ABOUT THAT
INTERIM PERIOD WHILE THE COLLEGE
IS SEEKING ACCREDITATION EYES OF
THE MAYOR OF EVENTS AT SOME
ADDITIONAL. PROTECTIONS WHILE
THE COLLEGE IS SEEKING
ACCREDITATION THE WORKFORCE
INVESTMENT BOARD AND THE
COMPLAIN EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT WILL DETERMINE
WHETHER THE PROGRAMS OFFERED BY
THE ONLY COLLEGE HAD JOB MARKET
VALUE TO CALIFORNIA INDUSTRIES.
THE PROPOSED COLLEGE ALSO
DIRECTS THE COLLEGE AT
EXCUSE ME THAT PROPOSED LANGUAGE
ALSO DIRECTS THE COLLEGE TO
EXPLORE PROCESS FOR ALLOWING
STUDENTS. WHO ATTEND THE COLLEGE
WHILE THE COLLEGE IS SEEKING
ACCREDITATION TO OBTAIN CREDITS
AFTER THE COLLEGE BECOMES
ACCREDITED?
IN THE AREA OF CURRICULUM THAT
MAYOR VISION PROPOSES LANGUAGE
THAT CLARIFIES THAT CURRICULUM
DEVELOPED BY THE COLLEGE AND ITS
FACULTY WOULD HAVE THE SAME
ACADEMIC PROTECTIONS GRANTED TO
THAT CURRICULA DEVELOPED BY
OTHER. ALCHEMY COLLEGE FACULTY.
AND THE PROPOSED A TRAILER BILL
ALSO CLARIFIES THE INTENT OF THE
ONLY COLLEGE TO CREATE UNIQUE
CONTENT AND DELIVER IT IN A
MANNER THAT IT'S NOT DUPLICATIVE
OF THE PROGRAMS OFFERED. BY
OTHER AT LOCAL COLLEGES
I THINK YOU I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
OKAY THANK YOU ALEJO.
A GROUP ROLE WITH THE LEADS THAT
AMOUNT THOUGHT FIFTH.
WE HAVE.
THE SAME CONCERNS THAT WE HAD
WITH THE ORIGINAL JANUARY
PROPOSAL I'M HAVING
FUNDAMENTALLY OUR CONCERNS ARE
THAT THE. THE AND THE PROPOSAL
THAT MISTRESS INTO THAT IDENTIFY
SPECIFIC PROBLEMS WITHIN THE
EXISTING COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM THAT'S PREVENTING THEM
WORKING ADULTS FROM ECHO THING
THESE PROGRAMS. AND IT DOESN'T
CLARIFY HOW THE NEW COMMUNITY
COLLEGE WITH THE NEW ON MY
COMMITTEE BECAUSE WHAT EXIT
DRAFT THE SPECIFIC BARRIERS THAT
EXIST FOR WORKING ADULTS.
SO WE WOULD LIKE OUR RECOMMEND
REJECTING THE PROPOSAL AND.
I'M IF YOU ARE INTERESTED WE DO
THINK THAT WE GROWTH
ADMINISTRATION THAT THE THINGS
THEY.
THAT WORKING ABOUT THE DON'T
HAVE POST SECONDARY OUR
CREDENTIALS ARE A A GROUP THAT
CAN BE ECONOMICALLY VULNERABLE
AND. DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR THAT FOR
THAT PARTICULAR GROUP I'M A IS
IT SOMETHING GOOD AND THAT
SHOULD BE EXPLORED BY WE JUST
THINK YOU CAN EXPLORE THOSE
OPTIONS THROUGH TIME MAKING
OTHER SYSTEM MIGHT IMPROVEMENTS
THAT DON'T INVOLVE CREATING AND
ON THE COLLEGE.
AND CHRISTMAS WHEN YOU THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WE REMAIN
SUPPORTIVE OF THE ONLINE COLLEGE
WE THINK THAT BE ABOUT THE
CHANGES THAT THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE.
SCRIBE A RESPONDED MUCH OF THE
FEEDBACK THAT WE'VE HEARD OVER
THE PAST SEVERAL MONTHS FROM OUR
BOARD OF GOVERNORS FROM OUR
CONSULTATION COUNSELING FROM
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS. I THINK THE
TWO MOST PROMINENT.
PIECES OF FEEDBACK WE HEARD FOR
MANY WERE.
AROUND GOVERNMENTS AROUND
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING WE THINK A
YOU KNOW WE HAVE BEEN COMMITTED
TO EFFECTIVE PUBLIC GOVERNANCE
WE'VE BEEN COMMITTED TO A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING WE THINK
THE TRAILER BILL REFLECTS OF
BOTH OF THOSE I COMMITMENTS.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY WELL ABOVE QUESTIONS.
MR MEDINA WOULD LIKE TO START.
THE QUESTION.
.
HOW HOW DOES THE MAY REVISE?
GOVERNANCE
OF THE ONLINE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
HOW IS THAT DIFFERENT FROM THE.
INITIAL PROPOSAL.
AS SO UNDER THE INITIAL PROPOSAL
AND A NEW DISTRICT WOULD BE
CREATED WITH THE NEW INDEPENDENT
GOVERNING BOARD OF THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS WHAT'S THAT. WOULD
SERVE AS THE INTERIM.
BOARD UNTIL THE AND YOU
INDEPENDENT BOARD IS A POINT AND
I'M UNDER THAT UNDER THE MAYOR
VISION PROPOSAL THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS WOULD SERVE AS AT. THE
GOVERNING BOARD OF THE ONLINE
COLLEGE.
SO THAT THAT'S STILL A NEW.
COLLEGE THEN IT'S A NEW DISTRICT
IT'S STILL A NEW DISTRICT THAT.
CORRECT IT WOULD BE AND IT WOULD
BE NEW COLLEGE.
AND FOR PURPOSES OF THE STATUTE
WE WOULD DEFINE AT THE COLLEGE
ALLIES AT A DISTRICT AS WELL.
IT WOULDN'T SEEK ACCREDITATION.
IT WOULD SEEK ACCREDITATION
OKAY I'M NOT UNDERSTANDING HOW
THAT'S DIFFERENT FROM THE
INITIAL PROPOSAL.
AT THE THOSE GOVERNING BOARD.
WOULD BE THAT PORTER GOVERNOR'S
RIGHT MOVING FORWARD.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS THE INITIAL
PROPOSAL.
THAT THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS OUT
WOULD SERVE IN AN INTERIM ROLE
UNTIL AN APPOINTMENT UP AT
SEPARATE BOARD OUT WOULD BE AND
UP APPOINTED AND OTHER HIGHER
VERSION THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS
WAS GONNA POINT ANOTHER BOARD.
AND NOW THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS
WOULD RUN THIS ON MY COLLEAGUES
ARE SAYING AND AT CORRECT THAT
THERE WAS.
AT STATUE THAT'S BY THE BY THE
THE APPOINTMENT OF.
THAT THAT THE NEW INDEPENDENT
BOARD AND NOW THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS WHICH TO SERVE AS.
BUT NOT NOT NOT AS AN INTERIM
BUT INDEFINITE CORRECT.
IS THERE A PROBLEM WITH PROP
NINETY EIGHT FUNDING GOING TO A
DISTRICT WHOSE GOVERNOR BOARD.
IS NOT ELECTED.
CHRIS ORGASM APPLYING THE WITH
FINANCE WE BELIEVE THAT.
THE STRUCTURE OF THE TRAILER
BILL WITH SUCH THAT THIS COLLEGE
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR
PROPOSITION NINETY.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THE
GOVERNING BOARD IS NOT ELECTED.
YES.
WE BELIEVE THAT WE.
WHAT IT REALLY COMES DOWN TO IS
THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS IT'S PART
OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM
WHICH IS PART OF THE PUBLIC
EDUCATION SYSTEM?
ROOM
YES MISTER VOEPEL.
YES RIGHT NOW YOU'RE SET UP FOR
I. T. CREDENTIAL IN MEDICAL
CODING CREDENTIAL. NOW.
I MAY BE PUTTING THE CART BEFORE
THE HORSE HERE BUT DO YOU HAVE
ANY OTHER CREDENTIALS IN MIND
FOR THE FUTURE.
SO EVEN WORKING OVER THE PAST
FOUR MONTHS SINCE BUT GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL WAS RELEASED TO KIND OF
EVALUATE A SITE OF.
CREDENTIALS THAT WOULD BE
OFFERED UP YOU KNOW OUR.
PURPOSE OR YOU KNOW THAT THE
WORK THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING HAS
BEEN DO IDENTIFY SOME DESIGN
PRINCIPLES.
BANG CLEARED OFFERING AREAS
OFFERING CREDENTIALS IN AREAS
WHERE THERE'S A.
THE EXPECTATIONS OF EMPLOYMENT
GROWTH WHERE FOLKS CAN SEE.
EARNINGS GAINS WORK AND AND I
THINK IMPORTANTLY WHERE ARE WE
DON'T SEE DUPLICATION IN THE
COLLEGES TODAY AND SO ARE THOSE
OF THE TWO WE'VE IDENTIFIED IF
THIS PROPOSAL IS APPROVED BY THE
LEGISLATURE. OUT WE HAVE A SET
OF OTHERS.
BUT I THINK WE'RE STILL VETTING
I THINK THE COMMITMENT WE HAVE
CONSISTENT AT THE TRAILER BILLS
THAT WE WOULD OFFER THREE
PROGRAMS BEGINNING IN TWENTY
NINETEEN.
THANK YOU
USER.
OKAY MISTER O'DONNELL.
YES THANK YOU I'M THINKING
APPRECIATE SOME THE CHANGES THAT
ARE MADE HERE. AGAIN JUST TO
CLARIFY THIS OP COLLEGE WOULD
SPECIFICALLY THAT HE SAID ABOUT
THE MISSION OF.
OF PROVIDING.
SKILLS RIGHT TO CLOSE MAYBE
SOME SKILL GAPS IT'S NOT TO
OFFER GENERAL EDUCATION.
COURSES.
THAT'S CORRECT THAT'S CORRECT
RATE I'M.
SO IT IS. IN THIS CAN BE LIKE A
ONE STOP SHOP.
WHERE YOU HAVE GO?
AND.
TAKE AN ONLINE CLASS IS THAT
CORRECT.
I'VE THE ONLY COLLEGE WOULD
DESIGN A SPECIFIC.
A CREDENTIAL PROGRAMS SUCH AS
THE MEDICAL CODEINE AND THE IT
SUPPORT.
FOCUS ON SPECIFIC.
INDUSTRY AT NEED SO THAT WOULD
BE FOCUS SPECIALIZED PROGRAMS I
DON'T THINK ANYONE SUPPOSED TO.
CLOSING ACHIEVEMENT GAPS OR
DRESSING.
REALLY ECONOMIC NEEDS ACROSS THE
STATE WITH YOU KNOW PROVIDING
INDIVIDUALS MORE SKILLS.
SO THIS DE IN THE IDEAS THAT
YOU'VE GOT A COUPLE IDEAS NOW
CONCEPTS WHERE YOU'D GO WITH
THIS BUT THAT IT WOULD EXPAND
OVER TIME.
THAT KIND OF VISION.
RIGHT I THINK THERE'S A TIME
FRAME WHERE AT THE COLLEGE WOULD
INITIALLY DEVELOP THREE PATHWAYS
AND THEN THREE ADDITIONAL
PATHWAYS THE FOLLOWING YEAR AND
AGAIN THESE ARE SHORT TERM.
CREDENTIALS AT THAT LEAD TO A
PROMOTION AND OR WAGE GAINS
SPECIFIC INDUSTRIES BUT THE IDEA
IS THAT THE COLLEGE WOULD
CONTINUE TO. ADD DEVELOP AT
PROGRAMS AND DESIGNED AROUND
SPECIFIC.
WORK FOURS AT NEEDS AND CLOSING
ECONOMIC GAPS.
THIS IS ONE PLACE YOU GO TO.
TO TAKE CLASSES TO.
THERE.
GAIN THOSE NECESSARY SKILLS.
SO SO I GOT ALL I JUST STRUGGLE
THIS LITTLE BIT IS.
DO
DO WE HAVE THOSE CLASSES NOW
ACROSS THE STATE.
COLLEGES NOW OFFER THOSE
CLASSES.
I AM SO A COUPLE OF OF AND AREAS
WHERE THIS COLLEGES WHAT WILL BE
DIFFERENT HAD THEN THE EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE. I'M OF THE
COMMITTEE COLLEGES THE ON MY
COLLEGE WOULD DEVELOP I'M
PROGRAMS WITH THEIRS AND NEED.
WHERE?
WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE IS A
POSSIBILITY FOR I'M INDIVIDUALS
TO BE ABLE TO PROMOTE AND
INCREASE THEIR WAGE GAIN AWARE
THAT NEED AS AN BEING AT MATT'S.
THAT COLLEGE WOULD ALSO DEVELOP
COMPETENCY BASED EDUCATION.
AND OFFER AND COURSES THAT ARE
NIGHT TIED TO THE TYPICAL
ACADEMIC AND CALENDAR STILL AND
THE DESIGN.
OF OF THESE PROGRAMS WILL BE A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT AND WE DID
ADD SPECIFIC LANGUAGE IN THE
TRAILER BILL TO ENSURE THAT I
LESSONS LEARNED IT BY.
THE COLLEGE WOULD BE SHARED
ACROSS THE OTHER COMMITTEE
COLLEGES ON HOW TO BEST SERVE
OUT WORKING ADULTS THAT ARE.
CURRENTLY ATTENDING AND THICK
THE TRADITIONAL COMMUNITY THIS.
SIDE I DON'T OPPOSE THE GO THE
GOAL. I'M JUST A LITTLE CONFUSED
ON WHY THIS IS THE WAY TO GET
THERE WE HAVE ALL THESE COLLEGES
ACROSS THE STATE.
WHY WOULDN'T WE CREATE A ONE
STOP SHOP A ONE IN A ONE ONE
WEBSITE?
THAT WOULD HAVE ALL THESE
DIFFERENT CLASSES LISTA BECAUSE
THERE'S DIFFERENT SCHOOLS SKITS
SKILLSETS ACROSS OUR STATE
DINNER REGION'S THAT NEED
DIFFERENT SKILL SETS.
.
SO SO HELP ME UNDERSTAND WHY YOU
JUST WOULDN'T.
HAVE THESE COLLEGES DEVELOP
THESE NOW OR EVEN IF THEY OFFER
THEM NOW.
AND HAVE THEM COLLECTED ON ONE
WEBSITE ARE THE ON ONE WEBSITE
NOW. HELP ME I DON'T UNDER I
DON'T KNOW SEVEN SAY IN GENERAL.
WE ARE TARGETING AREAS WHERE.
COLLEGE ME COLLEGES MAY OFFER
SIMILAR PROGRAMS I THINK IT'S
FINANCE INDICATED.
COLLEGES AREN'T OFFERING THESE
PROGRAMS IN A COMPETENCY BASED
FORMAT I THINK THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THIS PROPOSAL
WE THINK.
.
CAN WE THINK IT HELPS REDUCE THE
FRICTION THAT STUDENTS NEED.
THAT STUDENTS OFTEN FACE AND I
IN ORDER TO GET ACCESS TO THE
PROGRAMS THAT LEAD TO WAGE GAINS
IN EMPLOYMENT.
.
I THINK IN GENERAL THE SCALE
ISN'T THERE I THINK YOU KNOW
CHANCELLOR OAKLEY HAS BEEN VERY
CLEAR THAT THE.
GOAL OF THIS IN PART IS TO
CREATE AN INSTITUTION THAT CAN
DELIVER INSTRUCTION AT SCALE TO
STUDENTS TO. A CAN OF STRANDED
WORKERS WERE FACING THIS NEED SO
I THINK.
.
YOU KNOW WE DON'T HAVE SKILLED A
DAY.
I THINK A QUESTION IS COULD YOU
BUILD SCALE AND THE EXISTING
COLLEGES WE THINK BE APPROACH IS
PREFERABLE TO BUILD IT IN A NEW
COLLEGE WHERE YOU CAN DESIGNED
SPECIFICALLY AROUND THE NEEDS OF
THE USE THAT BUT THIS POPULATION
OF LEARNERS.
CURRENT.
AMERICA WOULD JUST HAVE A BIG
PROBLEM ASSEMBLY MEMBER DONNA
YOUR QUESTION THE BIGGER PART OF
WHAT I THINK WE FEE OF A.
A DIFFICULT PATH PART OF
EVALUATING THE PROPOSALS THAT A
LOT OF THINGS HERE AND DEPENDING
ON WHAT YOU THINK OF THE MORE
IMPORTANT GOAL YOU WOULD TAKE TO
A DIFFERENT APPROACH SO. I THINK
WHAT YOU'RE SUGGESTING IS CAN
WE.
FIND A BETTER WAY TO SORT OF
COLLECT ONLINE PROGRAM TO MAKE
IT EASIER FOR STUDENTS TO ENROLL
IN THESE PROGRAMS ALL ACROSS THE
STATE. BECAUSE YOU'RE CORRECT
THAT THERE ARE ONLY ON LIKE.
COURSES ALL ALL ACROSS THE STATE
ENTIRE PROGRAMS MIGHT NOT BE
ONLINE THEY'RE AVAILABLE WE HAVE
A SYSTEM THAT DOES THAT. THAT IS
NOT VERY USER FRIENDLY BECAUSE
IT IT WERE STILL REQUIRES
INDIVIDUAL COLLEGES ARE
DISTRICTS TAXI BUT YOU CAN GO
ONLINE FIND OF COURSE CLICK ON
AND YOU HAVE TO WAIT FOR THE
COLLEGE TO. A SUBMIT SUBMIT
INFORMATION TO YOU CAN VERIFY
YOUR ENROLLMENT AND IN GENERAL
YOU CAN JUST SEEM IF WE DO THAT.
IF WE CREATE THAT ON MY COLLEGE
DOES NOT GONNA PICK THEM EVENT
THAT'S GOING TO CREATE ANOTHER
WEBSITE WHERE YOU CAN GO TO FIND
THE PROGRAM SO IF THAT'S THE
GOAL THAT'S ONE ASPECT.
THAT THAT THE WAY THIS PROPOSAL
HAS BEEN ITS THIRD MORE ABOUT IF
NOT ABOUT THAT ITS ABOUT WORKING
ADULTS AGE WHO WHO NEED
ADDITIONAL PROGRAMS. THAT YOU
MIGHT THINK IT'S WHOLLY
DIFFERENT APPROACH YOU MIGHT
THINK OKAY WELL WE WE REALLY
WANT A COMPETENCY BASED PROGRAM
LET'S FOCUS ON THAT LET'S.
FIGURE HOW TO DO THAT I THINK WE
WOULD SAY IF YOU'RE GOING TO DO
THAT.
YOU WANT IT YOU MIGHT WANT FOR
MORE OPTIONS THAN JUST CREATING
A NEW ENTITY THAT CAN HAVE A FEW
PROGRAMS YOU MIGHT WANT TO THINK
ABOUT POLICY CHANGES ACROSS THE.
THE ENTIRE SYSTEM THAT WOULD
IMPROVE IT BUT AGAIN IT DEPENDS
ON WHAT YOUR GOAL IS THAT WHAT
YOU THINK IS THE MOST IMPORTANT.
BIG FOCUS ON THIS IS KIND OF
FUN TO DO MANY THINGS THAT WERE
NOT ALWAYS YOU KNOW DEPENDING ON
THE WAY WE TALK ABOUT THE
SOMETIMES IT'S WIDEN ASPECT OF
MORE PUTTING THEM UP IN THE
OTHER. YEAH HIT THE WAY I'M
LOOKING AT THIS WE ARE TO HAVE
THE WILL.
I WAS THE THE HUB.
AND I I SEE THEM CREATING A NEW
WHEEL AND A NEW HUB.
THAT'S WHY I'M STRUGGLING WITH
THIS AND I I BELIEVE THEY HAVE A
COMPOSITION NOW TO DO THIS.
IT PROBABLY AN EVEN MUCH MORE
TIMELY MANNER AND WE'RE CREATING
A NEW BUREAUCRACY A NEW
ADMINISTRATION. WHEN YOU HAVE TO
PLAY OVER HERE WHAT COULD YOU
WHO JUST HAVE ONE PLACE YOU
COULD APPLY QUITE FRANKLY ONE
PLACE YOU APPLY FOR ALL
COMMITTEE COLLEGES IN THE STATE.
AND THEN YOU COULD ACCESS ALL
THOSE CLASSES ON THE WHEEL AS
OPPOSED TO AGAIN REINVENTING.
THE WHOLE NEW.
APPROACH AND THEN THEY'D BE
STILL BE SEPARATE.
WE'RE LOOKING AT REALLY IS
INTEGRATING.
NOT. A GOOD ANYONE COMMENT DID
YOU KNOW I WOULD JUST SAY I I
THINK WE. WE COULD HAVE THE
WHEEL I DON'T THINK WE HAVE THE
WHEEL TODAY SO I THINK THE
ARGUMENT THAT.
MANY MAKE IS THAT YOU COULD
BUILD OUT THESE TYPES OF COURSES
AT SKILLED THE EXISTING
COLLEGES.
I THINK WE THINK IT'S A
COMBINATION OF OF ALL OF THE
ABOVE THAT. ON THE EXISTING
COURSES IN WHAT WE CALL THE.
A WE AYE OUR ONLINE EDUCATION
INITIATIVE.
I THINK WE YOU KNOW WE AGREE
THAT THERE'S MORE WORK TO DO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET CALLS OUT
THERE'S MORE WORK TO DO TO BUILD
THOSE INTO ASSOCIATE DEGREE
PATHWAYS.
AND SO WE WILL BE DOING THAT
WORK SIMULTANEOUSLY I THINK
THERE'S THIS GAP OF WHERE ARE
THE COMPETENCY BASED PROGRAMS
THAT MEET THE NEEDS ARE FOR
WORKING LEARNERS. THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE THINK THE
ONLINE.
NOT BE ONLINE COLLEGE WILL HELP
TO ADDRESS
BUT I THINK WE NEED TO FIGURE
OUT AND AND PART OF WHAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ALSO OF A
YOU KNOW. SUGGESTS IS THAT HOW
DOES THIS NEW ONLINE COLLEGE
FEED INTO A PATHWAY IN OUR
EXISTING COLLEGES SO I THINK ALL
OF THE STRATEGIES ARE THINGS
THAT. WE AGREEMENT SENSE WE
THINK ESTABLISHING A NEW ONLINE
COLLEGES AND IT IS AN IMPORTANT
PART OF KIND OF THAT OVERALL
STRATEGY AROUND ONLINE
EDUCATION.
AROUND EDUCATION FOR WORKING
LEARNERS AROUND WHAT ARE
COLLEGES DO GENERALLY.
YEAH I I DON'T THINK YOU'RE
WRONG I JUST ANOTHER YOU'RE
RIGHT.
MY HEAD. OF ME.
I AGAIN I JUST HOPE THE
COMMITTEE WILL CONSIDER.
THE CHAIR YOU TO AYE AND AND
WHAT THEY TOLD ME LOOKS LIKE
BECAUSE AGAIN IF WE HAVE
CAPACITY AROUND THE STATE.
AROUND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WIRE WE THEN GOING TO REINVENT
IT PUT IN JUST ONE PLACE.
SO IF THERE IS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT. AFTER A FEW MORE
QUESTIONS OUT ICE WANNA FOCUS.
TYPICALLY ON THE FACULTY AND THE
STUDENTS THAT'S.
PART OF WHAT HIGHER EDUCATION IS
ALL ABOUT.
SO FIRST.
FIRST WITH THE STUDENTS
SO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
TALK ABOUT.
THE NEED FOR MORE EDUCATION
HIGHER EDUCATION BEYOND HIGH
SCHOOL INKED CREDIT YOU KNOW.
JOB FORCE THAT TODAY AND
TOMORROW AND YOU KNOW WE WE LAID
OUT AND YOU'VE LAID OUT A LOT OF
RESEARCH IS TALKING ABOUT
STRANDED WORKERS AND WHERE THEY
ARE.
AND.
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT HOW RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT.
THAT THE TYPE OF STUDENTS THAT
ARE SO CALLED MISTREATED WORKER.
BOX TRADITIONALLY DON'T DO WELL.
IN ONLINE EDUCATION ONLINE ARE
TO CASES USING THE ONES WITH
MORE EDUCATION WITH EITHER AT.
SOME COLLEGE R. RD A DEGREE
GETTING AT ANOTHER DEGREE TO
SUCCEED AND A LOT OF THAT IS THE
IS THE SUPPORT SERVICES AND.
NOW THAT'S A BIG PART OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WHY SOME
PEOPLE DON'T SUCCEED BECAUSE.
THEIR EDUCATION.
HOW BASIC AM? YOU KNOW
BACKGROUNDS AND WHEREWITHAL TO
MANEUVER THE HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM IS THAT DOESN'T ALWAYS
WORK.
AND SO. HOW IS THIS GOING TO
ADDRESS
STUDENTS IN SUPPORT SERVICES AND
OTHER WORDS IT? YOU KNOW.
IF YOU'RE HAVING TROUBLE THE
CLASS THERE'D SCOUTS LAYING IN
STATE STAFF HOURS AND ALL THAT
AT A CUBICLES CAMPUS AND SO HOW
HAVE YOU ADDRESSED.
IT'S THE STUDENT NEEDS IN THIS
PROPOSAL NUMBER ONE.
SURE I THINK IT START. ANSWERING
A QUESTION.
SO A COUPLE OF AREAS AND AS A
STUDENT SUPPORT SERVICES OUT
WILL BE KEY IN THIS PROPOSAL AND
AS OUTLINED AS PART OF THAT AT
LEGISLATION.
THERE'S A RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT UNIT THAT WOULD BE A
CORE COMPONENTS OF THE ONLINE
COLLEGE THAT WILL FOCUS ON.
ADDRESS SEEN ANY GAPS AND NEEDS
AND. PROVIDING THE APPROPRIATE
SUPPORT SERVICES UP FOR THEIR
STUDENTS OUT ONE OF THE AREAS
THAT THE.
I TRAILER BILL OUTLINES IT'S AT
TWENTY FOUR HOUR AND SUPPORT
SERVICE AND AT COUNSELING AND
TUTORING BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT A
LOT OF STUDENTS WHO ARE OLDER
WHO ARE TAKING ONLINE COURSES.
WHEN THEY NEED THE HELP IT'S TEN
PM ON A SUNDAY NIGHT SO
DEVELOPING A SUPPORT STRUCTURE A
UP WITH AYE COUNSELING AYE
TUTORING AYE. AT HOURS WHERE IT
MEETS US STUDENTS AT NEEDS AS
ONE COMPONENT THAT'S OUTLINED
WHAT HAPPENS IF THIS DIDN'T ONCE
SAID TO TALK TO SOMEBODY IN
PERSON STEPS PEOPLE ALWAYS LIKE
TO CALL THAT. APPLE TECH LINE
WHEN IT SOMETIMES GET A LIVE
PERSON OR MAYBE GO TO THE APPLE
STORE AND TALK TO SOMEBODY
THAT'S MAYBE NOT RIGHT EXAMPLE
BUT. YOU KNOW STUDENTS ARE THE
SAME WAY SO.
IT IS THERE A HYBRID MODEL
WHERE STUDENTS COULD GO IN AND
IT EVEN IF IT'S NOT TEN O'CLOCK
MAKE AN APPOINTMENT FOR DURING
THE WEEK AND. TALK TO A REAL
LIFE PERSON BECAUSE.
THAT'S WHAT BRING STUDENTS TO
SUCCESS
IN AND.
.
THE THROUGHOUT TIME THROUGHOUT
OUR EXPERIENCE GOING BACK.
YOU KNOW DECADES.
I WOULD SAY YOU KNOW I'VE I
THINK WERE WE'RE PROBABLY RIGHT
I REIMAGINE AND AS PART OF OUR
DESIGN PROCESS WE RECOGNIZE THAT
IN PERSON.
CONNECTIONS MATTER THAT A LOT
OF YOU KNOW WE HELD THE DESIGN
SESSION.
YOU KNOW A FEW MONTHS AGO AND
ONE OF THE BIG THINGS WE LEARNED
FROM OTHER FOLKS WHO DO WORK IN
THE SPACE IS THAT YOU NEED TO
KIND OF COACHING AND MENTORING
IS A BIG PART OF THIS WORK IN
THAT YOU NEED. BOTH KIND OF WELL
SO COACHING AND MENTORING IS
IMPORTANT AND SO CAN IF HAVING A
ROLE THERE THAT.
MAYBE IS FACE TO FACE BUT I
THINK IN MANY CASES THE HOUSE
HOW WILL THAT COACHING AND
MENTORING WORK. IN PERSON OR YOU
TAXING SOMEBODY ON YOUR ANDROID.
PHONE AT THREE IN THE MORNING
WHO'S MAYBE LIVES IN FLORIDA I
THINK THERE'S A SO NOT IN
FLORIDA I THINK WE'VE MADE A
COMMITMENT THAT.
IT OUT THAT THESE THAT THE
STAFF IS BASED IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT I DO THINK THAT PART OF.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE EXAMPLES OF
WHERE THAT COACHING MENTORING
WORKS WELL ONLINE AND WE THINK
IN MANY CASES IT WORKS BETTER
ONLINE YEAH.
BUT IT DOES SPACE DON'T SEE
STARTED RISK RESPECTFULLY NOT
ANSWER EITHER OF YOU ARE WELL
WILL BE. A PHYSICAL IN PERSON
PLACE WHERE STUDENTS CAN ENGAGE
IF THEY WOULD LIKE TO I THINK IN
GENERAL WE IMAGINE THAT THERE
ARE IN PERSON AND.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INTERACTION
WE DON'T YET KNOW WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE I THINK MUCH OF THIS
DESIGN.
YOU KNOW WE'VE.
WE'RE TRYING TO DESIGN AT THE
SAME TIME IS TRYING TO KIND OF
RESPOND TO KIND OF FEEDBACK
WE'VE HEARD BUT I THINK YOU KNOW
WE'VE HEARD LOTS OF FEEDBACK
ABOUT NEEDING SOME TYPE OF IN
PERSON INTERACTION. I THINK
WE'VE MADE A COMMITMENT TO TO
HAVING THAT IMPRESSIVE
INTERACTION LOW THAT LOOK LIKE
IS AN ONLINE.
UNIVERSITY FOR CALIFORNIA OF
SOMEBODY IN COACHELLA.
IN CHICO.
SACRAMENTO SAN JOSE.
AND BAKERSFIELD SO HOW HOW WILL
THAT PERSON IF THEY COLLEGES
HERE. YET DOWN AND YOU KNOW RED
CIRCLE OVER WHAT HAVE YOU EVER
THE LOS RIOS HAS A SITE THEY
WANT TO HAVE THIS.
HOW WOULD THAT HOW WOULD THAT
WORK AND I PROBABLY DON'T HAVE A
SPECIFIC ANSWER IF YOU WANT ON
THE KIND OF EXACTLY HOW IT WORKS
AYE MATCH YOU KNOW I THINK THAT
IS WHY YOU HAVE IMPORTANT
INFORMATION TO KNOW? WHAT THINK
IT YOU KNOW PART OF THIS WE HAVE
MADE THE CASE THAT AN IMPORTANT
PART OF DOING THIS WORK AND
SCALE IS BEING ABLE TO DO IT
ONLINE SO I DON'T WANNA NAM? CAN
I WOULDN'T CONCEDE THE FACT THAT
WE CAN'T OFFER A VARIETY OF
SERVICES THAT FOLKS
TRADITIONALLY IMAGINE NEED IN
PERSON INTERACTION THAT WE
COULDN'T DO THAT ONLINE AND
WE'VE SEEN EXAMPLES IN OTHER
CONTEXTS. OF WAYS IN WHICH FOLKS
DO THAT ONLINE I THINK THE.
A PLACE WHERE A LOT OF UP IN OUR
DESIGN PROCESS A LOT OF THE IN
PERSON INTERACTION. IS NOT
NECESSARILY BETWEEN TENTATIVE
THE NEED OF OF THE STAFF PERSON
AT THE COLLEGE IN THE STUDENT
BUT THAT YOU OFTEN WANT KIND OF
COHORTS OF STUDENTS WHO ARE
GOING THROUGH THIS EXPERIENCE
TOGETHER. TO HAVE A SUPPORT
NETWORK TO.
TO MAKE THIS FEASIBLE AND SO
WE'VE SPENT A LOT OF TIME
THINKING ABOUT HOW DO YOU
IMAGINE KIND OF INTERMEDIARY
ORGANIZATIONS ARE HOW DO YOU
BUILD A SENSE OF COMMUNITY. A
LOT OF WHAT WE'VE.
DON IS KIND OF I THINK CRITICAL
TO THIS.
PROPOSAL IS THE PARTNERSHIPS
THAT WE'VE HAD WITH EMPLOYERS
AND WITH TOM LABOR ORGANIZATIONS
UNIONS OUT TO FIND EMPLOYEES AT
THEIR WORK SPACES. DESIGNED
INSTRUCTION THAT IS RELEVANT TO
THEM IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE.
BOTH KIND OF.
EMPLOYMENT AND ACHIEVE EARNINGS
GAINS IN THAT.
AND THAT WORK ENVIRONMENT SO I
THINK. THAT THE STRUCTURE THAT
WE'VE DESIGNED FOR A PER FIRST
PATHWAYS IS CAN WE DESIGN
PATHWAYS WHERE WE HAVE A SET OF
EMPLOYEES WHO WITH ADDITIONAL
SKILLS.
COULD ACHIEVE SOME TYPE OF A
LABOR MARKET OUTCOME THAT WE
THINK IS IMPORTANT.
OKAY I'M NOT.
QUITE CERTAIN THAT THAT
ADDRESSES
THAT THAT THAT ISSUE BUT BUT
I'LL MOVE ON.
AS FAR AS THE THAT THE
BARGAINING ISSUE FOR IT FOR THE
FACULTY.
HOW WILL THAT WORK IS
APPARENTLY?
THAT YOU'D HAVE TO ABBOTT
DISTRICTS
DO THE BARGAINING FOR THE NEW
CAMPUS WHICH IS RUN BY THE BOARD
OF GOVERNORS YEAH THAT HOW THAT
ALL THE CIVIC ONE OF THE
CONCERNS THAT WE HAD HEARD ABOUT
THE GOVERNOR'S AYE JANUARY
PROPOSAL WAS AMBIGUITY AROUND.
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING IN THE
INTERIM SO I THINK WHAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL DOES.
HIS PROVIDE SOME CERTAINTY THAT
ONE THIS COLLEGES ESTABLISHED
THERE'S A PROCESS FOR COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING UNDER EXISTING
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING LAWS. AND
SO THE OUR ONLINE COLLEGE WE
CONTRACT WITH THE DISTRICT THE
DISTRICT WOULD SERVICE THE PARTY
IN TERMS OF.
THE EXISTING COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING LAWS AND THE ONLINE
COLLEGE WOULD APPEAR TO BE OF
THE TERMS OF THAT AGREEMENT.
AND WERE THESE BE.
PART TIME FACULTY POSITIONS.
THEIR FULL TIME FACULTY I THINK
WE HAVE MADE A CLEAR COMMITMENT
THAT WE WILL HAVE FULL TIME
FACULTY OF THE COLLEGE.
ALL OF THEM. I NOT ALL OF THEM
IN THE THE GOVERNOR'S TRAILER
BILL SUGGESTS THAT THERE WOULD
BE A COMBINATION OF FULL TIME
AND PART TIME BUT WE HAD
EXPECTED HER TO THE SOFA.
TO THE RIGHT ARE THE
EXPECTATIONS OF LAWLER AROUND
HOW WE.
.
HOW WE ADMINISTER?
A FACULTY SYSTEM THAT HAS BOTH
PART TIME FULL TIME. AND THEN
YOU MENTIONED AND THIS THE
CONCERN EARLIER.
I THINK MISTER DON ABOUT A
COUPLE MONTHS AGO.
AS FAR AS WHERE THE FACULTY
MEMBERS WHO WOULD BE.
SEVEN IT THEY WOULDN'T THEY
COULDN'T BE AN ITEM OR FLORIDA
OR SOMEWHERE THAT THEY HAVE TO
BE CALIFORNIA. RESIDENTS AND HOW
DO YOU ENFORCE THAT.
I THINK THAT THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WILL PROBABLY HAVE TO WORK
OUT BE THINK OF THE GOVERNOR'S
TRAILER BILL AND AND FINANCE
SINCE RICHARD PROBABLY BETTER
THAN I CAN BUT THE GOVERNOR'S
TRAILER BILL MAKES A CLEAR
EXPECTATION THAT WE ARE
RECRUITING IN CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE COMMITTED TO HAVING
CALIFORNIA FACULTY CALIFORNIA
BATES FACULTY.
AND YOU SAID THAT YOU YOU THINK
YOU NOW HAVE. BUY IN FROM FROM
FACULTY AND WE HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENT LATER BUT YOU MEANT I
HELPED WRITE AND SAY THAT WE
HAVE BY AND FROM FACULTY AYE I
THINK WE RESPONDED TO MUCH OF
THE CONCERNS I WILL LET THEM
SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES BUT.
.
BUT BUT IF I IF IT SOUNDED LIKE
A SUBURB PATIENT PUBLIC WHO
WANTS TO EXPAND.
EXPRESS THEIR OPINIONS ON THIS
BUT BUT WE DO THINK THAT WE
RESPONDED TO MUCH OF THE
FEEDBACK THAT WE HEARD.
AND THEN AGAIN JUST GOING BACK
TO WHAT WAS ASKED EARLIER SO SO
YOU'RE YOU'RE ALL CONVINCED
THAT.
YOU COULDN'T DO THIS THROUGH AN
EXISTING.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND AND I
THINK OTHER WORDS I THINK SAN
DIEGO. PROPOSE THIS LAST LAST
FALL BUT THEY COULD BE
THE CALIFORNIA HAVE. OF THIS
WORKING WITH OTHER COLLEGES
COMMITTEE COLLEGES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND AND YOU'RE
CONVINCED THAT THAT. WOULDN'T.
BE.
.
THAT WOULDN'T BE AT THAT A GOOD
OPTION TO TO REACH TO STRANDED
WORKERS ACROSS CALIFORNIA I
THINK GIVEN THE RESOURCES WE
HAVE IN THE.
AND.
.
THE CRITERIA WE'VE APPLIED THAT
WE WANT TO DO THIS THAT SCALE WE
WANT TO DO THE SENATE COMPETENCY
BASED WAY WE WANT TO. TARGET
THIS POPULATION OF STUDENTS AND
DESIGNED SPECIFICALLY AROUND
THIS POPULATION OF STUDENTS.
I THINK GIVEN THOSE PRIORITIES
AND THE.
AND THE PARAMETERS IN THE
BUDGET WE THINK THIS IS THE BEST
WAY TO ACHIEVE THAT OUTCOME.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
SO THAT MR MEDINA.
ON LITTLE CONFUSED ON THE
STRUCTURE.
STILL ON ON GOVERNANCE AND
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING.
SO WE HAVE YOU WOULD HAVE A.
THE GROUP THE.
TRUSTEES.
THE.
BOARD OF GOVERNORS.
RIGHT BOARD OF GOVERNORS WHO
WOULD ACT.
AS.
TRUSTEES FOR THIS NEW COLLEGE
CORRECT. AT CREDIT RIGHT.
THEY WOULD HIRE PRESIDENT.
CORRECT.
AND THAT PRESIDENT WOULD BE ON A
DIFFERENT COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CAMPUS.
I KNOW OR HE WOULD BE WHERE.
THAT I.
THAT PRESIDENT WOULD BE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE ONLINE COLLEGE
AND WHERE WOULD HE BE
PHYSICALLY.
.
I DON'T THINK THAT CAN DETERMINE
THE UP.
LET'S YOU KNOW EXACTLY WHERE THE
THE THE HEADQUARTERS OF THIS
OPERATION WOULD BE LOCATED.
BUT THIS THE FACULTY WOULD
BARGAIN WITH SOMEONE ELSE.
A PARTNER DISTRICT THE COLLEGE
BUT CONTRACT WAITED A PARTNER
AYE IN EXISTING PARTNER DISTRICT
TO ESTABLISH A COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT FOR THE
FACULTY OF THE COLLEGE WITH
ANOTHER DISTRICT. AT CORRECT THE
OTHER DISTRICT IN EXISTING TO AN
EXISTING DISTRICT SO FAR
UNSPECIFIED.
CORRECT DO YOU HAVE A PRESIDENT.
OF IT OF THE. DISTRICT.
FOR COLLEGE WHO REALLY DOESN'T
BARGAIN WITH HIS OWN FACULTY.
ARE NOT DIRECTLY UNDER THE UNDER
THE TERMS OF THE LAW.
SO SO THE BARGAINING MEMBERS OF
THE ACT COLLEGE THIS ONLINE
COLLEGE WOULD ACTUALLY BE. OF
FACULTY OF A DIFFERENT COLLEGE.
I THINK THAT WOULD BE DETERMINED
THAT'S PART OF THE AGREEMENT
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
BARGAIN WITH WITH WITH WITH
THEIR NOT INVITING WITH THE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES ARE NOT GOING
TO BARGAIN WITH THE.
.
RIGHT RIGHT FOR THE PURPOSES OF
WHAT WE TRADITIONALLY THINK OF
AS KIND OF THE EMPLOYMENT
RELATIONSHIP OF WHO DIRECTS THE
WORK WHO MANAGES THE EMPLOYEES
THEY WOULD BE EMPLOYEES OF THE
ONLINE COLLEGE. I THINK FOR
PURPOSES OF COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING.
WE HEARD A LOT OF FEEDBACK THAT
WE HAD BEEN.
.
THAT IT WAS UNCLEAR HOW
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING WOULD WORK
PARTICULARLY IS THIS COLLEGES
SET UP AND SO WE THINK IT'S ARM
A WORKABLE. STRUCTURE THAT MAKES
SENSE TO.
TO MAKE CLEAR THAT COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING APPLIES IMMEDIATELY
AND THIS IS HOW WE WOULD MAKE IT
AFFECT HOW EFFECTUALLY BUT I
WOULD JUST POINT OUT THAT AT A
MINIMUM IT CERTAINLY.
CUMBERSOME.
THIS NEW.
STRUCTURE.
AND WHO THE FACULTY REPORTS TO.
AND.
WHO THEY BARGAIN WITH?
UNDERSTOOD THE ONE PIECE THAT I
WOULD ADD TO THAT IS THAT IT
WOULD BE A SEPARATE BARGAINING
UNIT AT THAT COLLEGE SO IT
WOULDN'T BE WITHIN. THE EXISTING
AGREEMENT OF THAT THE PARTNER
DISTRICT.
OKAY.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER LIMON. THANK
YOU. AT A THINK THAT THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF CONVERSATION AND
DIALOGUE ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL AND NOT JUST LIMITED TO
THIS BUILDING.
BUT REALLY I THINK AT THE
STATEWIDE LEVEL I KNOW THAT.
I FOR ONE HAVE HEARD ABOUT IT.
IN THE DISTRICT A WITH MULTIPLE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND I GO BACK
TO SOME OF MY EARLIER REMARKS ON
IN THIS PARTICULAR AT COMMITTEE.
ABOUT SOME OF THE ELEMENTS THAT.
.
CONTINUE TO BE.
CONVERSATIONS OR.
OF INTEREST IN IN IN MOVING
FORWARD ON I A THINK YOU'VE
HEARD FROM MULTIPLE COLLEAGUES
AT THE PIECE ABOUT LAYING AT IN
TERMS OF LANGUAGE AND CLARITY
ABOUT. WHO THE FACULTY WERE
GONNA BE ARE THEY GONNA HAVE?
BARGAINING UNITS WHO WOULD BE
NEGOTIATING I THINK IS IMPORTANT
IT SOUNDS LIKE THERE IS.
IN INTEREST IN KNOWING WHAT
THAT IS. AND SECONDLY ARE YOU
KNOW A COUPLE MONTHS AGO I
MENTIONED.
THE QUESTION WHY NOT THIS BE A
PILOT WHY NOT UNDERSTAND WHETHER
OR NOT ON THIS IS GOING TO BE
GOOD FOR THE LONG TERM.
YEAH THIRDLY ON IF IT'S A IF
IT'S CONSIDERED A PILOT PROGRAM.
ON THE IDEA OF CREATING.
BOARD OF TRUSTEES SEEMS A
LITTLE PREMATURE.
IN UNTIL WE UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
ROLE IS AND.
FOURTH AND THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF CONVERSATION ABOUT REALLY
LIMITING THE COURSES TEND NOT
TO.
BEING THOSE THAT ARE ALREADY
OFFERED BY EXISTING COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND SO I WANTED TO
SHARE SOME OF THOSE PIECES JUST
BECAUSE THEY FEEL LIKE THOSE ARE
PIECES.
THAT ARE STILL OUT THERE.
EIGHT SEEMS AT THE REPEATEDLY
GET BROUGHT OUT BUT I ALSO THINK
THAT IN SOME WAYS AND
CONSIDERATION OF SOME OF THESE
PIECES WOULD ALLOW FOR. PERHAPS.
EXIT YOU KNOW AT A TIPPING TAD
BIT MORE COMFORT AND
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THIS COULD
LOOK LIKE BOTH IN THE SHORT TERM
AND THE LONG TERM. I'M SO I
WANTED TO SHARE THAT AND KNOW
THAT THIS IS.
PART OF IT. HAS IT IN REACHED UP
THE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT.
WHAT WE THINK OF ONLINE ON IT
LEARNING I'M ALTOGETHER AYE AND
I APPRECIATE THAT WE'RE
CONTINUING TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION BUT I DO HOPE THAT?
IN EFFORT TO.
BUT TO BRING MORE STAKEHOLDERS
I'M ALL INTO SOMETHING I THINK
THAT.
.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO GET MORE FOLKS
ON BOARD BECAUSE IF WE DON'T
THIS IS NOT GOING TO BE
SUCCESSFUL WE WE CAN'T.
.
IT'S IT'S A RICH A REALLY HARD
THING TO MAKE SOMETHING
SUCCESSFUL WHEN THE STAKEHOLDERS
I DON'T HAVE THE SAME LEVEL OF
BY AN INVESTMENT WHERE THEY HAVE
CONCERNS FROM THE. BEGINNING ON
ANYTHING IF THERE IS A
COMMITMENT FOR THIS TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AND NOT JUST TO BE
SOMETHING THAT.
YOU KNOW POTENTIALLY HAPPENS A
YEAR TO AND THEN.
WITH THAT NEW GOVERNOR ANY
LEGISLATURE GOES A DIFFERENT
DIRECTION THAN I THINK THAT THE
EFFORTS UP FRONT TO TRY TO MAKE
THIS.
A DIFFERENT A DIFFERENT TYPE OF
A PROGRAM COULD BE ON MORE
HELPFUL.
THANK YOU I THINK THAT CELL THAT
THAT'S ALL FOR NOW.
WE'LL COME BACK TO THIS ITEM.
AT A LATER DATE.
ISSUE NUMBER TO THE GOVERNOR'S.
FUNDING FORMULA PROPOSAL AND
THERE REVISIONS.
FROM THE LAKE LATEST MAY REVISED
POST.
I'VE MORE IT'S IT WOULD KEY SO
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
AYE SINCE THE RELEASE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE HAS ENGAGED
COLLEGE LEADERS AND STAKEHOLDERS
ON THE PROPOSED AT FUNDING AT
STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING
FORMULA.
THE MAYOR VISION INCLUDES
ADJUSTMENTS AND RESPONDS OUGHT
TO FEEDBACK AND RECOMMENDATIONS
BY THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AS
ALL HIGHLIGHTS AT THOSE CHANGES.
OF FIRST THE ME REVISION
INCLUDES ADJUSTMENTS TO THE
OVERALL FRAMEWORK OF THE FORMULA
THEY WERE VICE FORMULA REFLECTS
A AT REVISED OVERALL
DISTRIBUTION OF SIXTY PERCENT OF
THE BASE ALLOCATION. TWENTY
PERCENT OF THE SUPPLEMENTAL
ALLOCATION AND TWENTY PERCENT AS
A STUDENT SUCCESS INCENTIVE
ALLOCATION ND AGAIN THE BASE
ALLOCATION REFLECTS AN
ALLOCATION BASED ON A ROMANCE.
BE AYE SUPPLEMENTAL ALLOCATION
REPRESENTS AB IN ALLOCATION
BASED ON HIGH NEED AT STUDENTS
ENROLLMENT OF HIGH NEED
STUDENTS.
AND THE STUDENT SUCCESS
INCENTIVE ALLOCATION IT'S BASED
ON AT SPECIFIC SUCCESS METRICS.
ADVOCATES REVISED AT
DISTRIBUTION WHEN WE BELIEVE AT
SOME ADDITIONAL STABILITY TO.
COLLEGES HAS EIGHT I WOULD
TRANSITION TO A NEW FORMULA.
I I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT ONTHE
BASE AT ALLOCATION OUTSIDE THE
MARRIAGE AND PROPOSES USING A
THREE YEAR ROLLING AVERAGE TO
CALCULATE ENROLLMENT FOR
PURPOSES OF THE BASS GRANT TO
BETTER PROTECT. I'D DISTRICTS UP
FROM A ROMAN SWINGS AND IN
RESPONSE TO THE IMPACT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSED OF
FUNDING FORMULA NONCREDIT
INSTRUCTION. THE MAYOR VISION
PROPOSES TO CONTINUE TO FIND
NONCREDIT INSTRUCTION AT AT THE
EXISTING RATES SO OUTSIDE OF
THAT AT PROPOSED FUNDING
FORMULA.
THE MAYOR VISION ALSO REVISES A
SUPPLEMENTAL ALLOCATION TO
INCLUDE THE NUMBER OF LOW INCOME
STUDENTS OVER THE AGE OF TWENTY
FIVE RECEIVING A COLLEGE PROMISE
CRAP FEE WAIVER.
AB FIVE FORTY STUDENTS AND THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF STUDENTS
RECEIVING A PELL GRANT.
THE MAYOR VISION ALSO REVISES
THE STUDENT SUCCESS ALLOCATION
METRICS TO BETTER REFLEXIVE
PROGRESS METRICS AND ALIGNED
WITH THE GOALS OF THE VISION
FIRST
EXCESS.
THE REVISED METRICS INCLUDE
COMPLETION OF ASSOCIATE DEGREES
AND CERTIFICATES OVER EIGHTEEN
UNITS ADAM ASSOCIATES DEGREES
FOR TRANSFERS.
SUCCESSFUL TRANSFER TO FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTIONS COMPLETION OF
TRANSFER LEVEL MATH AND ENGLISH
IN THE FIRST YEAR. OBTAINING
ORIGINAL LIVING WAGE WITHIN A
YEAR OF COMPLETING A DEGREE OR
CERTIFICATE PROGRAM AND
SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETING NINE
UNITS OF CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION COURSES.
IN RESPONSE IF YOU BACK ABOUT
THE TRANSITION TO THE NEW FOR
FUNDING FORMULA AND AND THE HOLD
HARMLESS THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES A TWO YEAR ABSOLUTE
HOLD HARMLESS RATHER THAN ONE
YEAR. THIS WOULD ENSURE THAT NO
DISTRICT WILL RECEIVE LESS AND
BOTH EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND
NINETEEN TWENTY AND RECEIVED AND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN.
ADDITIONALLY THE MARAVICH ARE
PROPOSES A HUNDRED AND FOUR
MILLION ONE TIME PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND TO
PROVIDE ONE TIME I'D
DISCRETIONARY RESOURCES TO
DISTRICTS TO ENSURE THAT EVERY
DISTRICT. OUT HAS A YEAR OVER
YEAR A FUNDING INCREASE FROM
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN TO EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN THAT REFLECTS A GROWTH
OF AT LEAST TWO POINT SEVEN ONE
PERCENT.
IN REGARD TO.
TOO CATEGORICAL CONSOLIDATION
AND ADD THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
DIRECTOR THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
TO DEVELOP A PROPOSAL FOR THE
MAY REVISION. THAT WOULD
CONSOLIDATE CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS
BASED ON THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
RECOMMENDATIONS THE MAYOR OF
ASIA PROPOSES TO INTEGRATE THE
STUDENT SUCCESS THAT'S APART
PROGRAM THE STUDENT EQUITY
PROGRAM AND THE STUDENT SUCCESS.
OF FOR BASIC SKILLS PROGRAM
THESE PROGRAMS ALL SEEK TO SERVE
AT THE SAME STUDENT POPULATIONS
AND CONSOLIDATING THEM WOULD
GIVE DISTRICTS AND HANDS
FLEXIBILITY AND FOR THEIR BELTS
ON AT THE GUY PATHWAYS
FRAMEWORK.
OUT WE WOULD NOT THAT IT'S
PROPOSAL DOES NOT IMPACT
ETHIOPIA'S AT FUNDING FOR
VETERANS RESOURCE CENTERS OUT
FOSTER IN THE FOSTER YOUTH
PROGRAM OR THE DISABLED A
STUDENT AT PROGRAM SO THOSE
REMAIN. A SEPARATE CATEGORY WAS
AND THANK YOU AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS.
OKAY. THANK YOU HELLO.
A GROUP CALLED THE LEAD SAID
ABOUT WITH A FIFTH.
WE ARE GENERALLY ARMS YOU KNOW
WE WERE GENTLY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
FUNDING FORMULA I'M AT THE
RIDLEY PROPOSE THAT WE DO THINK
OVERALL. THIS THIS PROPOSAL IS
IS THAT BETTER PROPOSAL THAN
WHAT WAS IN JANUARY AND THEN
ADDRESS THE SEVERAL OF THE
CONCERNS THAT WE HAD. OMINOUSLY
FARM MOST RE THE MOST IMPORTANT
ONE IS THAT THE. HAVE THE MORE
PER PERFORMANCE BASED FUNDING
THAT SPECIFICALLY TIED TO THE
OUTCOMES OF LOW INCOME STUDENTS.
ARE AND AND WE THINK THAT IS AN
IMPORTANT I'M A ISSUE THAT
WASN'T THERE IN JANUARY THAT WE
THINK HELPS ENSURE THAT THERE'S
MORE. INCENTIVE FOR COLLEGES TO
REALLY FOCUS ON IMPROVING OTHER
SUPPORT IMPROVING THE OUTCOMES
OF OF LOW INCOME STUDENTS.
I'M NOT ALTHOUGH WE WE RECOGNIZE
THAT WE THINK THE UP ABOUT A
PROPOSAL THAT IN JANUARY WE DID
HAD RECOMMENDED ADOPTING I THINK
WE RECOGNIZE THOUGH THAT. THE
LAB WE VERY FAST AND AND ARE YOU
DO NOT HAVE A LOT OF TIME TO
REALLY BUT THOROUGHLY BACK AND
REVIEW BALANCE OF OF THE
PROPOSED ON THIS IS A MORE
COMPLEX PROPOSAL THEM. BENT DOWN
WE HAD IN JANUARY THERE THERE
ARE A LOT THE OUTCOMES BASED
PORTION IN PARTICULAR IS THAT IT
IS MUCH MORE COMPLEX SO WE'RE
RECOMMENDING THAT YOU ADOPT THE
FRAMEWORK FOR THE PROPOSAL.
BUT NOT AND NOT TO BE
IMPLEMENTED UNTIL NINETEEN
TWENTY I'M AND THEN THERE IN THE
SUMMER THROUGH LEGISLATION I'M
YOU CAN BET THE SPECIFIC
COMPONENTS OF THAT OF THE
PERFORMANCE BASED.
AND THE FUNDAMENTAL GRANT
FUNDING TO REALLY MAKE SURE THAT
YOU FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH WHAT
THOSE PUT THOSE METRICS ARE THAT
WOULD GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT MORE
TIME TO. TO MAKE SURE YOU'RE
COMFORTABLE WITH BOTH METRICS
WHAT THE THING TIME I'M
BEGINNING SORT OF THAT SENDING
THE SIGNAL TO COLLEGE OF THE
WOULD BE MOVING THEM IN THAT
DIRECTION.
I'M IF YOU DID DO THAT THEN.
THERE IS ABOUT BY TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY NINE MILLION THAT MAY
REVISION A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION IN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN. AND THEN THERE'S A
HUNDRED AND FOUR MILLION THAT
WAS ADDED IN THE IN THE MIRROR
VISION THAT ARE ALL ASSOCIATED
WITH SORT OF HOLDING.
IT'S HARMLESS FOR THE TRANSITION
THAT FUNDING WOULD BE FREED UP
FOR ONE TYPES.
I'M WITH REGARDS TO THE BLOCK
GRANT I THINK YOU KNOW IT
SUPPORTIVE OF MOVING IN THE
DIRECTION OF CONSOLIDATING
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS SO WE WOULD
RECOMMEND. WE CAN ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSALS AT GOOD START WE WOULD
ACTUALLY RECOMMEND.
CONSIDERING ADDING ADDITIONAL OF
SUPPORT PROGRAMS INTO BLOCK
GRANT TO PROVIDE GREATER
FLEXIBILITY FOR DISTRICTS.
I'M WE WOULD ALSO OF.
RECOMMENDED YOU CONSIDER OUT OF
BED.
THINKING ABOUT THAT A NEW
FORMULA FOR THIS BLOCK GRANT
RIGHT NOW THE PROPOSAL IS THAT
YEAH DISTRICT WHO JUST RECEIVE
WHATEVER THEY HAD GOTTEN IN THE
PAST.
BOTTOM THINK THAT WE WOULD
RECOMMEND.
DEVELOPING IN THE FARM THAT'S
THAT THIS IS UPDATED IN THE
FUTURE AND A THIRD OF JUST
BECOME STALE AND SORT OF NOT
REFLECTIVE OF. OF DISTRICTS NEED
MOVING FORWARD. I'M HOW YOU
ACTUALLY.
KIND REDISTRIBUTIVE FOR MILLER
CHANGED THE FORMULA REALLY
DEPEND ON WHAT YOU WHAT YOU
DECIDE ON THE APPORTIONMENT
FACTOR FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU
DECIDED NOT TO DO. A NEW FUNDING
FORMULA YOU MIGHT WANT TO
CONSIDER MAKING THIS A BLOCK
GRANT A LITTLE BIT MORE TIED TO.
INFORMATION ON THE NUMBER OF
LOW INCOME STUDENTS TO DISTRICTS
SO THAT YOU ARE PROVIDING A
LITTLE BIT MORE FUNDING SO THAT
THOSE DIDN'T GET GREATER
SUPPORT.
I'M IF YOU DID ADOPTED THE
FUNDING FORMULA THAT HAD SOME
COMPONENT THE PROVIDED MORE THAN
FUNDING MAYBE WOULD NEED THAT
BUT WE DO THINK REVISITING THE
FORMULA NOT JUST LOCKING IT IN
PLACE OF THAT WASN'T SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN. HELPS INSURE THEM
MOVING FORWARD WERE ALIGNING OUR
FUNDING WITH WITH THE NEEDS OF
DISTRICTS.
THANK YOU COMMITTEE CALL JUST
RESPONSE WHEN YOU WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
TO BEGIN WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
I JUST WANT TO EXPLAIN THAT TO
THE DOCUMENTS THAT WE
DISTRIBUTED OF THE FIRST IS OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE FUNDING
FORMULA. SO THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
YOU KNOW AFTER THE JANUARY
BUDGET OUR OFFICE AND MANY IN
THE SYSTEM DID.
EXTENSIVE WORK TO EVALUATE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FIGURE OUT HOW
WE CAN IMPROVE THE FORMULA THIS
DOCUMENT IS THE A. IS THE
CULMINATION THE PRODUCT OF THAT
WORK AND SO.
IT OUT HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS ABOUT OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS WE APPRECIATE
THAT MOST OF OUR RECOMMENDATIONS
HAVE BEEN INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET SO THE SECOND
PACKET OF INFORMATION. SHOWS OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS COMPARED TO THEM
A REVISION PROPOSAL.
.
WE ADDRESSED BOTH THE FUNDING
FORMULA AND CATEGORICAL
CONSOLIDATION.
AND WE ARE.
PLEASED TO SEE I GOT MOST OF
THEM IN THE MIRROR VISION I
WOULD JUST SAY ANYTHING FOR. A
FEW REASONS.
YOU KNOW WE THINK THIS IS THE
TIME TO TAKE ACTION ON THE
FUNDING FORMULA. ONE WE THINK.
YOU KNOW THERE'S AN URGENCY
AROUND THE VISION FOR SUCCESS
THAT WE'VE TALKED MANY TIMES
THIS YEAR ABOUT OTHER GOALS THAT
WE'VE INCLUDED IN THE AUDITION
FOR SUCCESS. WE THINK THE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL REFLECTS
THOSE VALUES REFLECTS THE
MEASURES THAT WE THINK ARE
IMPORTANT OFFER COLLEGES TO MAKE
PROGRESS TOWARD. SECOND WE THINK
THAT.
NOW IS AN IMPORTANT TIME GIVEN
THE RESOURCES IN THE STATE
BUDGET FOR US TO BEGIN TO
ALLOCATE RESOURCES ACCORDING TO
OUR PRIORITIES TO DIRECT
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO LOW
INCOME STUDENTS INTO.
DEBIAN TO REFLECT THE A THE
FOCUS ON OUTCOMES THAT WE THINK
ARE ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT.
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS THANK
YOU ARE ALL START THE
QUESTIONING HERE AT FIRST OF ALL
I I DON'T THINK THIS IS A BAD
IDEA. AS FAR AS
A NEW FUNDING FORMULA
RECOGNIZING.
DIFFERENT STUDENT POPULATIONS
I'M NOT SURE IF THIS IS ALL
COOKED READY TO GO AS THE LA
ALLUDED TO. AT LAST YEAR'S
SUMMIT REALLY MONNING I
INTRODUCED LEGISLATION LOOKING
AT THIS CONCEPT AND WE ASK THE
ELLIOT HELPLESS. I FIGURED OUT
ON AN OVER ARCHING.
KINDA CONCERN I HAVE FOR THIS
IS.
IF IF YOU TRY TO COMPARE THIS TO
EXAMPLE LCF PFAFF WAS WE WENT
THROUGH A COUPLE YEARS AGO.
AT THE END OF THE DAY AFTER A
YEAR AND A HALF PROCESS
WE HAD CONSENSUS WITH.
.
THE AT THE END COALITION
COMMUNITY WITH THAT ACCESS AND
SCHOOL BOARDS AND. TEACHERS
UNIONS AND SO FORTH AND SO.
THAT IS IS VIC IS REALLY LACKING
HERE TODAY AND I THINK THAT
MAKES I MEAN I THINK THE
COMMITTEE. UNEASY ABOUT DOING
SUCH A A MAJOR CHANGE WHEN THERE
IS LOT OF CONSTERNATION AND
UNCERTAINTY. AND PERCEIVE MAJOR
WINNERS AND LOSERS AND WE HEARD
LOUD AND CLEAR FROM SOME OF THE.
DISTRICTS ACROSS THE STATE
EARLIER HEARING AND AND THE NEW.
RUNS THAT YOU CREATE THAT
YOU KNOW I THINK BRING A LITTLE
MORE CLARITY BUT THERE ARE STILL
SON. WHO HAD DIED A LOT OF
CONCERNS AND THE HOLD HARMLESS
SO I GUESS IT'S ANOTHER YEAR OF
HOLD HARMLESS BUT AFTER THE
THIRD YEAR?
IT'S KIND OF A CLIFF.
AND AND SOME OF THE DISTRICTS
THEY WOULD SENSI.
BUT THERE ALLOCATION WOULD BE
LESS THAN THEY WOULD GET.
UNDER JUST A BASIC COLA SO.
I'M.
NOT CERTAIN IF FOR ALL THEIR
GUIDES JUST YET DOWN PLUS THE.
THAT THE METRICS THAT WOULD
THAT WE PUT IN HERE FOR.
.
FLORA FOR SUCCESS I THINK THERE
ARE SOME QUESTIONS TO HELP OUT
WHICH WOULD WORK IF THEY'RE FAIR
OR IF WE SHOULD JUST.
BASICALLY GO TO WHAT MARCH WHICH
WE DID WITH LCF ACTRESS
RECOGNIZE THE STUDENT POPULATION
WHATEVER IT IS AND JUST FOCUS ON
THAT AND I'M I'M PROBABLY MORE.
ON THE.
IT INCLINED THAT WAY SO I DON'T
THINK THAT WE'RE YOU WORK YOU
WORK WERE READY TO DO WHAT I'M
DOING TODAY OBVIOUSLY BUT. AS
FAR AS RIGHT NOW ANTHONY REVISED
PROCESS TO IT TO EMBRACE THIS
I'M.
WHETHER IT'S LATER THIS SUMMER
OR EVEN BUT DOWN THE ROAD I
THINK THAT WE NEED TO HAVE.
A BROADER STAKEHOLDER PROCESS
YOU KNOW WITH.
FACULTY AND ACADEMIC SENATE
ENGAGED IN HELPING CRATER AND
I'D LIKE TO SEE WHAT WE SAW WITH
LCF AT THE END OF THE DAY.
EVERYONE'S IN FRONT OF US AMBER
EMBRACING US SUCH A CONCEPT AT
AND ALSO KNOW THAT THE CURRENT.
.
CURRENT COMMITTEE BECAUSE
APARTMENT FORMULA DOESN'T WORK
FOR ANYBODY. SLOW DEATH.
SPIRAL FOR SOME COMMITTEE CALL
DISTRICTS THAT WE NEEDED
KNOWLEDGE AS WELL SO.
THERE'S JUST SOME OVER ARCHING.
COMMENTS.
.
THE START THIS MORNING.
MISTER O'DONNELL BY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND I AGREE WITH
YOUR COMMENTS THERE AGAIN I MY
MY BIGGEST CONCERN HERE IS THE
WINNERS AND LOSERS.
BUT MORE PARTLY Y. THEIR
WINNERS AND LOSERS MAYBE YOU
COULD SPEAK TO THAT.
I'M. IT AND AND LOOK AT MY OWN
LONG BEACH CITY COLLEGE.
I'M WILL THE LONGISH COLLEGE
PROMISES WHICH IS BEEN A
SUCCESSFUL PATH. TO YOUR KIDS
OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL INTO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND ON TO THE
FOUR YEAR UNIVERSITY.
BUT WITHOUT IN A.
OFTENTIMES THAT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT THEY'RE NOT SUCCESSFUL.
THEY BOUNCED INTO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DID WHAT THEY NEEDED YOU
AND THEN BOUNCE OUR. IS MY
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY WOULD
ACTUALLY BE DOING BECAUSE IT OUR
STUDENTS DIDN'T GET.
THE A.
SO YEAH MAYBE YOU CAN SPEAK TO
THAT AND THEN WHAT IF I CHOSE TO
GO TO A COMMUNICABLE JIM TAKE UP
PHOTOGRAPHY COURSE.
FOR FOR PERSONAL ENRICHMENT BUT
ALSO SOME SKILLS.
.
BUT THAT DIDN'T LEAD TO A DEGREE
MAYBE I EVEN ALREADY HAVE A
DEGREE WHERE WHERE DOES THAT.
HOW DOES THAT PLAY INTO THE
FORMULA CAN YOU WALK ME THROUGH
THE?
SURE I AM SO WE DID RELEASE AND
SOME RAT AS SOME FORMULA
SIMULATIONS SWEET IT'S ABOUT
YOUR PROJECTIONS.
BASED ON THE VARIOUS AT FACTORS
AND WHY SOME DISTRICTS ARE
GROWING MORE THAN OTHERS.
IS A COMBINATION OF AREAS.
FACTORS TO SELL TYPICALLY
DISTRICTS THAT SERVE THAT OUR
HIGHEST AT A LOW INCOME STUDENTS
ADAM AND TO HAVE THAT.
HIGHS OUTCOMES TYPICALLY SEE.
AB MORE GROWTH THAN THAT OTHER
AYE AYE DISTRICTS.
I OF COURSE THERE ARE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT FACTORS THAT WE TRY TO
ADDRESS THAT THE AA ISN'T THE
ONLY ADDS SUCCESS AT METRIC AND
THE MAY REVISION. PROPOSES AYE
REVISIONS TO THOSE METRICS TO
INCLUDE OTHER THINGS LIKE AB
COMPLETION A TRANSFER LEVEL AT
MATH AND ENGLISH COMPLETION OF A
NINE CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION.
AYE UNITS WHO ARE TRYING TO
BALANCE AB BASED ON THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
RECOMMENDATIONS AYE THOSE
DIFFERENT PROGRESS AND AYE. AYES
SUCCESS AT METRICS AS PART OF
THAT ANY OTHER COMPONENT TO IT
IS THAT WE WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF ANSWERING
UNCERTAINTY OVER THE TRANSITION.
ONTO THE NEW FUNDING FORMULA.
SO.
WE EXTEND THAT THE HOLD
HARMLESS AN ABSOLUTE HOLD
HARMLESS FOR TWO YEARS.
AT WHEN WE DID OUR PROJECTIONS.
UP THAT WE RELEASED I WOULD
NOTE THAT THESE ARE BASED ON
JUST FIVE YEAR OUT PACK PRIOR
YEAR FIVE YEAR AVERAGES OF THE
DIFFERENT METRICS SO AS
COLLEGES.
I BEGIN TO AS THE MORE SUCCESS
IN FRANCE AND IMPLEMENTING SEVEN
A FIVE AND A STUDENTS OUT. OF A
BAD COMPLETING TRANSFER LEVEL
MATH AND ENGLISH WE SHOULD SEE
THOSE SUCCESS METRICS INCREASED
SO AGAIN THESE ARE PROJECTIONS
AND THERE'S HERE THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR COLLEGES AT TO
GROW FISCALLY BY NOT JUST ARE
ONLY MORE STUDENTS BUT BY. AYE
MAKING PROGRESS ON THOSE VARIOUS
METRICS.
SO I AM.
THAT'S CRAZY PUSHED OUT THE HOLD
HARMLESS PROVISIONS BUT.
SO YOU WAIT THREE YEARS AND YOU
OFF A CLIFF ALSO DOING IS
DELAYING THE INEVITABLE FOR SOME
POTENTIALLY.
BUT.
MY ONE OF MY MAIN CONCERNS HERE
IS VELOCITY.
I I DON'T KNOW THAT EVERY THIS
BUILDING HAS THE WORLD
EXPERIENCE THAT OTHERS HAVE.
I'VE MYSELF WAS A P. COLLEGE
WHAT FOR FIVE YEARS I WORKED.
IN A FULL TIME PART TIME.
SO I AM MY TIMELINE TO GET OUT
OF COMMUNICABLE IT'S WAS
EXTENDED DUE TO PERSONAL
CIRCUMSTANCES
DOES THE FORMULA CONTEMPLATE
THAT BECAUSE WE MIGHT HAVE
STUDENTS THAT ARE ONLY.
ABLE TO TAKE A CLASS IN YOUR
THIS THE COLLEGE SHOULDN'T GET
QUOTE UNQUOTE PUNISHED.
FOR THAT.
SURE.
.
AND MAYBE TO MAKE A FEW BROADER
POINTS THAT I YOU KNOW I JUST
WANT TO REITERATE FINANCES POINT
THAT YOU KNOW THE.
BUT THE PROPOSAL EXTENDS A HOLD
HARMLESS FOR SECOND YEAR WE
IMAGINE OVER THOSE TWO YEARS
COLLEGES ARE CHANGING BEHAVIOR
IN SUCH A WAY THAT.
THE DATE ON THAT PIECE OF PAPER.
ISN'T WOULDN'T BE NECESSARILY
BE REFLECTIVE OF THE DATA USED
TO CALCULATE FUNDING IN YOUR
THREE WE THINK THAT. YOU KNOW
THEY COR PROMISE OF THIS
PROPOSALS THAT OUGHT BY
IDENTICALLY REALLY IDENTIFYING
THE OUTCOMES WE CARE ABOUT CLEAR
IT PHILLY IDENTIFYING THE TYPES
OF STUDENTS WE THINK FACE
ESPECIALLY HIGH BARRIERS TO
SUCCESS. THAT OVER THE NEXT TWO
YEARS COLLEGES ARE CHANGING
BEHAVIOR IN SUCH A WAY THAT THE
DATA THERE ISN'T REFLECTIVE SO I
THINK FOR. DISTRICTS THAT IN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN IN NINETEEN
TWENTY WOULD BE GUARANTEED AS
MUCH AS THEY RECEIVED IN
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN FOR THOSE FOR
WHOM THAT THE FORMULA. DOESN'T
CURRENTLY ARE PROJECTED GROWTH
WE WE WOULD EXPECT AND WE WOULD
HOPE THAT.
THERE ARE.
OUTCOMES THAT. YOU KNOW THAT
THEIR OPTIMISM FOR IF I THINK
THE SECOND POINT AROUND UMMC A
CAN OF STUDENTS WHO TRANSFER
WITHOUT ASSERTIVE ARE WITHOUT A
DEGREE. OF THESE POPULATIONS OF
STUDENTS I THINK WHAT.
WE THINK THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL THE RECOMMENDATIONS WE
MADE UP BEGIN TO ALLIED WHAT'S
USED IN FUNDING FOR THE VALUES
THAT THIS LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR HAVE ALREADY.
HAVE ALREADY IDENTIFIED THAT
THE GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE
HAVE MADE AYE ASSOCIATE DEGREES
FOR TRANSFER A PRIORITY THAT WE
THINK THERE ARE CLEAR BENEFITS
TO A STUDENT WHO TRANCERS WITH
AN ADT. VERSUS STUDENTS WHO
TRANSFER OUT WITHOUT WHAT THE
PAY GET BENEFITS AT AT THE CSU
THAT NOW GET BENEFITS OF THE UC
BENEFIT WITH THEY GET THERE'S NO
REASON TO GET IN A FEW GO.
GONNA BE A WE ALL KNOW THAT THEY
HAVE PAID IT BUT I'M NOT GONNA
ARGUE OVER THAT THERE IS NO READ
TO SPEND MORE TIME GETTING A.
ACTUALLY DEFEATS YOUR GOAL WHICH
IS REALLY VELOCITY I THINK.
YOU'RE NOT YOU'RE NOT SOME WHERE
WE GOT VOLUME RIGHT AND THE GUYS
ARE INTERESTED VELOCITY BUT
AGAIN I'M STILL STUCK ON. PEOPLE
HAVE PERSONAL CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
DO NOT ALLOW THEM TO GET THROUGH
A DEGREE IN FOUR YEARS I THINK
SOME PEOPLE IN THIS BUILDING ARE
LIVING IN A DIFFERENT WORLD LOT
PEOPLE WORK HERE RIGHT FRANKLIN.
DID THAT THEY HAVE THE FINANCIAL
WHEREWITHAL. THEY IS THE MEANS
TO DO THAT BUT NOT EVERYBODY IN
THE WORLD HAS THAT SITUATION SO
WHAT WHAT ANYTIME MUCH CHANGING
BEHAVIOR WHAT BEHAVIOR ARE YOU
TRYING TO CHANGE. THE U. TRYING
TO CHANGE THE BEHAVIOR OF THE
COLLEGE OR THE STUDENT I DON'T
KNOW THAT.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU'RE GONNA
INCENTIVIZE A STUDENT TO GET
THROUGH IT FOR YEARS WHEN
THEY'VE GOT YOU HAVE CHILDREN AT
HOME A JOB THEY'VE GOT TO PAY
RENT. HE GOT A PAPER FOOD I
DON'T KNOW HOW THIS FORMULA IS
GOING TO ADDRESS THAT AND I
WOULD SAY BUT CLEARLY THE
COLLEGE I THINK THE HEAT CONTENT
OF THE BEHAVIOR CHANGES AT THE
COLLEGE LEVEL AROUND.
DEVELOPMENTAL EDUCATION AROUND
HOW STUDENTS ARE PLACED INTO
GUIDED PATHWAYS AROUND HOW
STUDENTS ARE ADVISED TO DEGREES
SO I THINK. FOCUSING ON.
A CREATING INCENTIVES FOR
INSTITUTIONS TO CLEARLY FOCUS ON
EDUCATIONAL GOALS INSTANCES I
THINK THE INTENT OF AFFIRMATIVE.
WHAT ABOUT VELOCITY ABOUT?
CAN I BE SPENT EARNING USE THAT
AS THAT CONTEMPLATED IN THE
FORMULA IT IS A CLEAR PART OF
OUR VISION FOR SUCCESS OUR
VISION FOR SUCCESS SINCE TOO
MANY STUDENTS TAKE MORE UNITS
THAN THEY NEED TO. SO YES I
THINK VELOCITY.
YOU KNOW WE DON'T.
SPECIFY A TIME PERIOD BUT I
THINK A V. FORMULA CREATES A
CLEAR INCENTIVE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO GET STUDENTS OUT.
APPROPRIATELY IN ED.
AS FAST AS THEY CAN AND AND I I
I AGREE WITH THAT.
BUT I AGAIN AND I'M STILL
CONCERNED THERE'S.
SOME KIND OF.
YOU KNOW.
DISINCENTIVE EVEN TAKE ON THE
STUDENT IS GOING TO TAKE A.
A PROJECTED PATH TO A DEGREE
WITH WITH THESE TYPES OF
FORMULAS.
AND TO HELP THEM TOWARD SUCCESS
BECAUSE ALL WE WE JUST ONE
PHILOSOPHY WHICH IS WHAT THE
LOS.
I WOULD ARE RIGHT I THINK
THEY'RE SEXY LEFT OF THAT.
THAT ASPECT IN THIS IT WITH ME
RIVETED IN PART BECAUSE. IN THE
JANUARY PROPOSAL HAD SOME AWARD
AMOUNT JUST SORT HOW MANY AWARDS
DO YOU ISSUE IF YOU'RE. THE
SECOND PIECE WAS A AWARD WITHIN
THREE YEARS SO THAT WAS A LOT
MORE PRIOR TO THIS IN GETTING
FOLKS OUT IN THREE YEARS.
THIS PROPOSAL DOESN'T HAVE THAT
COMPONENT WERE TIGHTENING IT BE
FUN. AT A THREE YEAR MARK THAT
DOES SORT OF IF YOU'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT THERE BEING THE TH.
THAT BUT YOUR YOUR AWARDS ARE
GOING TO DISINFECT BY THE
COLLEGE FROM REALLY PROVIDING
GOOD SERVICE TO SOMEBODY'S
APARTMENT DOMESTIC THERE'S A
LITTLE BIT LEFT IN THIS PROPOSAL
BUT I DO THINK THAT.
IF YOU GET YOUR GENERAL COMMENTS
THE GUARD PART OF WHY I THINK WE
HAVE TO GET THE PERHAPS THINKING
A LOT MORE TIME TO REVIEW THAT
THAT THE DATA BECAUSE THERE ARE
SOME. IMPLICIT SORT OF A THING
THAT WE GET WILL TRY TO
INCENTIVIZE THROUGH THIS FOR THE
RIGHT ONE OF THE FACTORS IS THAT
THE THE IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT HOW
MUCH.
PERFORMANCE BASED FUNDING A
COLLEGE WOULD GET THEY GET MORE
FUNDING FOR AN ASSOCIATE DEGREE
FOR TRANSFER.
ARE A LITTLE BIT LESS FOR AN
ASSOCIATE DEGREE AND THEN LEFT
THE MAP FOR A TRIP FOR A
TRANSFER WITH NO DEGREE. I THINK
THAT THE REASON THAT THERE ARE
SOME REASONS YOU WHAT MIGHT WANT
TO DO THAT YOU MIGHT WANT TO.
ENCOURAGE IN A THIRTY DEGREE FOR
TRANSFER BECAUSE THAT MIGHT HELP
STUDENTS FIND ACT AUTHORED BY
UNIVERSITY HAVE MORE OPTIONS FOR
WHAT WE'RE COLLEGES THAT COULD
USE WHEN THEY'RE TRANSFERRING.
YOU MIGHT WANT TO BE ABLE TO
ENSURE THAT IF FOR WHATEVER
REASON THEY DROP OUT THEY HAVE A
DEGREE THERE ARE SOME REASON WE
WANT TO THAT BUT I THINK.
IT HAVING SOMETIME DIRECT THINK
ABOUT HIS AFFECTS.
THE FACT THE FORMULA PROBLEMS
DIFFERENT.
AMOUNTS EFFECT FROM I THINK
IT'S WOULD BE GOOD TO MAKE SURE
EVERYBODY IS SORT OF ON THE SAME
PAGE AND UNDERSTAND. THEM
PERFECT THANK YOU BYE SO
STUDENTS CAN ANYONE UP HERE TELL
ME WHY ONE WOULD WANT TO GET IN
THIS IF THEY'RE IF THEY'RE
PLANNING ON GOING TO.
SAY THEIR LONG WE SEE COLLEGE
OF PLANNING ON ALONG THE STATE
WHY THEY WOULD WANT TO GET IN A
A.
AND NOT JUST TRANSFER OVER TO
LONG BEACH STATE LIKE I DIDN'T
GET AN A I TRANSFERRED OVER I
THINK SO WHY WOULD I WON A AS
OPPOSED TO JUST TRANSFERRED OVER
SPECIFIC ENTRANCE ROVER QUICKER.
ALL JUMP IN WITH THREE REASONS.
FIRST THAT.
IF YOU TRANSFER THE NECESSITY
FOR TRANSFER YOUR GUARANTEED
ADMISSION OF ARE YOU AT BUT
DON'T IF YOU MEET THE TRANCE
REQUIREMENTS DON'T YOU GET.
WELL YOU DON'T HAVE THAT SAME
GUARANTEES THAT YOU'RE
GUARANTEED ADMISSION TO THE CSU
SYSTEM YOUR PREFERENCES AND THE
LOCAL CAMPUS WHO I LIKE WE HAVE
THE COLLEGE PROMISE IN LONG
BEACH WE'VE GOT THAT. I THINK IN
GENERAL SO ON A STATEWIDE BASIS
I THINK IN PLACES WHERE THERE
HAVEN'T BEEN THAT.
CLEAR PATHWAY FROM OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO THE C. I
THINK I'M. A* UP PRESENTS A
BENEFIT THERE PA UNDER THE
STATUTE BUT THE CSU.
YOU ARE YOU HAVE TO TAKE NO
MORE THAN SIXTEEN UNITS SO I
THINK THERE'S A COMMITMENT TO
CHECK IT OUT A FASTER TIME TO
DEGREE AT THE CSU. AND I THINK
FOR STUDENTS TO.
UPON TRANSFER WHO MAY NOT
FINISH A BACHELOR'S DEGREE I
THINK HAVING A CREDENTIAL.
HAS CLEAR LABOR MARKET BENEFITS
PERSONS HAVING SOME COLLEGE BUT
NO DEGREE.
IT DOESN'T REALLY SOUGHT REASONS
BECAUSE.
I I JUST DON'T FIND THOSE TO BE
REAL SOLID REASONS I APOLOGIZE
BUT I JUST.
I DON'T THINK THIS IS THOUGHT
THROUGH WHEN THEY'RE ALTERNATE
CALL.
TO GET A BA AND HOPEFULLY EVEN
AN A OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
I DON'T I DON'T. I I'VE NEVER
HAD ANYONE ASK ME FOR MY A. I'VE
HAD PLENTY OF PEOPLE ASK ME FOR
MY BA.
THANK YOU THANK YOU JUST YEAH
CHAIRMAN OF I MEAN. WILL
CHAIRMAN YOU ARE CHAIRMAN OF THE
EDUCATION YOU'RE THE CHAIR THERE
THAT'S RIGHT I DON'T KNOW THAT I
WENT TO LONG BEACH STATE
UNIVERSITY LIFE YOU. TRANSFERRED
FROM MERRICK RIVER COMMUNITY
COLLEGE RIGHT DOWN THE ROAD
HERE.
GOT MY FIFTY SIX UNITS DIDN'T GO
FOR THE A A BECAUSE BY DOING
GETTING THE A WHAT IF ANOTHER
SEMESTER.
WASTING AROUND AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE I KNOW THAT'S RIGHT
UNDERSTAND WE'RE GETTING MORE
TIME AND. IN DIFFERENT PLACES
THANK YOU SO.
A GOOD POINT.
OKAY.
WE WILL.
.
I SEE TO THE NEXT ITEM ISSUE
NUMBER THREE.
IS THERE SAM. VARIOUS COMMUNITY
CALLS PROPOSALS AND MAYBE YOU
CAN JUST RUN THROUGH THESE
REALLY FAST.
SO I JUST HAD LATE SEVERAL NEW
INVESTMENTS FOR THE
COMMUNICATIVE AS AN AREA OF
FINANCIAL AID AT THE MAYOR
REVISION PROPOSES SEVEN POINT
EIGHT MILLION PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND. UP FOR THE
PROPOSED STUDENT SUCCESS
COMPLETION GRANT TO REFLECT
INCREASE ESTIMATES OF ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS.
AS WELL AS THIRTEEN POINT FIVE
MILLION ONE TIME AND FIVE
MILLION ONGOING PROPOSITION
EIGHTY GENERAL FUND. TO ALLOW
COLLEGES TO OPERATE THEIR
FINANCIAL MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS FOR
MORE EFFICIENT PROCESSING OF AN
ENTRY TO STUDENTS.
THE MAYOR.
IT'S WOMAN COMMUNICATOR
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS AS WELL
AS AN INCREASE OF FIVE POINT
NINE MILLION ONE TIME I
PROPOSITION EIGHTY GENERAL FUND
A BACK FOR SHORTFALLS IN
RELATED.
AND SUPPLEMENTAL INSTRUCTION
HOURS THE PRIOR YEAR AND THIS IS
JUST CONSISTENT WITH OUR
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL WHICH
IS UPDATE AT THE ESTIMATE BASED
ON. UPDATED I AM ARE IS AYE
HOURS AND OTHER FACTORS.
THE MERE VISION ALSO INCLUDES AN
INCREASE AT SIX MILLION ONE TIME
PROPOSITION EIGHTY GENERAL FUND
TO EXPAND THE DEVELOPMENT OF
OPEN EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES AT
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THE MAYOR VISION INCLUDES ADAM
AN INCREASE OF FIVE MILLION
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND TO EXPAND THE NECKS UP
PROGRAM WHICH SUPPORTS CURRENT
AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AND THIS
WOULD ALLOW THE PROGRAM TO
EXPAND TO TWENTY. AT
COMMUNICATES DISTRICTS.
AND THE LOTS ADJUSTMENT I WILL
HIGHLIGHT IS A ONCE A SIX
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND ONE
TIME PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND. TO CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THE WORK AROUND THE
COURSE IDENTIFICATION NUMBERING
SYSTEM. AB THANK YOU AND HAPPY
TO ANSWER CUTTING. LA OF ANY
THOUGHTS OR CONCERNS WITH THESE
PROPOSALS YES SURE INVOLVED
WITH%
THEM WE DID HAVE THAT I THINK
ARE ARE NOW OFF WITHIN ON PAGE
TWENTY TWO FIGURE ELEVEN WE HAVE
A SUMMARY OF ALL OF OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSALS I WON'T GO
INTO. ALL OF THE DETAILS I JUST
HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF THEM
BETTER BETTER NEW PROPOSALS.
UNRELATED TO THE FINANCIALLY
TECHNOLOGY.
WHEW IT'S FIVE MILLION ONGOING
THIRTEEN HAVE MILLION ONE TIME
WE RECOMMEND REJECTING THE
PROPOSAL WE THINK THIS IS THE
KIND OF.
THROUGH A BASE OPERATIONS
ACTIVITIES THAT SHOULD BE FUNDED
WITH APPORTIONMENT.
I'M THREE HUNDRED PROJECT ARA
RECOMMEND REJECTING THAT AND
THEN ON THE OPEN EDUCATION
RESOURCES TOM WE RECOMMEND
ADOPTING IT BUT WE ACTUALLY JUST
RECOMMEND THAT.
FOR THE NEXT FIRST THREE YEARS
THAT THERE ARE SOME ANNUAL
REPORTS ON WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
IT. WITHOUT FUNDING TO GET A
BETTER SENSE THAT HAVE BETTER
OVERSIGHT OF WHAT'S GOING ON.
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS THAT ANY OF THAT THE
QUICKLY.
THANK YOU WERE SUPPORTIVE OF.
PROPOSALS WE THINK WE THINK
BECAUSE OF THE GOVERNOR THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE FOR INCLUDING
EXCESS COMPLETION GREAT THANK
YOU.
NO QUESTIONS ON THESE ITEMS WILL
RULE THAT.
HAVE A. RESPONSE IN OUR PLAN
NEXT WEEK.
WE'LL PROCEED NOW WITH THE UC.
MAY REVISE.
PROPOSAL.
NUMBER FOUR.
OKAY BERMAN FINANCE.
GOOD MORNING JAX WELL DEPARTMENT
FINANCE.
BEFORE I GET INTO THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSALS I WOULD LIKE
TO AGAIN HIGHLIGHT THE.
NINETY ONE POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN THE UC MADE
A GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. THIS
REPRESENTS A SUSTAINABLE
INVESTMENT IN HIGHER EDUCATION
THAT.
YOU KNOW WE'VE WE'VE MAINTAINED
IN THE MADE PROVISION.
THE FIRST INITIAL DISCUSSES THE
FIFTY MILLION WITH HELD IN THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN BUDGET ACT.
AT THAT WOULD BE RELEASED
CONTINGENT ON THE UC
IMPLEMENTING THE RECOMMENDATIONS
OF THE STATE AUDITOR.
COMPLETING ACTIVITY BASED
COSTING ACTIVITY BASED COSTING
PILOTS.
ATTAINING A TRANSFER RATIO OF
TO ENTERING FRESHMEN STUDENTS
FOR EVERY WHEN TRANSFER STUDENT.
ENDING SUPPLEMENTAL RETIREMENT
PAYMENTS TO SENIOR MANAGEMENT
NEW SCENE SENIOR MANAGER GROUP
EMPLOYEES.
AND RELEASING ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION REGARDING THE
FINANCES.
THE UC HAS SUBMITTED EVIDENCE
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
REGARDING THEIR PROGRESS ON
THESE GOALS AND UPON REVIEWING
THIS EVIDENCE WE HAVE DETERMINED
THAT THE UC HAS MADE A GOOD
FAITH EFFORT. TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS IN THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN BUDGET ACT.
HOWEVER I SOME PIECES OF.
THIS AGREEMENT.
ARE PENDING IN THE MAY REGION'S
MEANING SPECIFICALLY IN REGARDS
TO CERTAIN DISCLOSURES OF
FINANCIAL INFORMATION
PRESENTATION OF BUDGET THAT WE
WILL REVIEW. AT THE REGENTS
MEETING LATER THIS MONTH.
.
OUR NEXT PROPOSAL AYE IT
REGARDING EASY PATH.
EASY PATH AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN IS GOING TO BE THE
POINT TWO ADDITIONAL CAMPUSES.
OUT OF THIS BUDGET MAINTAINS THE
PRACTICE OF TO DIRECTLY
APPROPRIATE. FOR THE UC OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT AND THE C. PATH
PROJECT HOWEVER IN LIGHT OF
THESE. ADDITIONAL COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH IMPLEMENTING THE
PROJECT.
WE HAVE INCLUDED PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD ALLOW THE UC
TO RETURN FOR A FEE FOR SERVICE
FOR THIS INCREMENTAL FIFTEEN
POINT THREE MILLION NEEDED TO
EXPAND. AND POOR THIS PROJECT
I IF YOU SEE DETERMINES THAT
ADDITIONAL FUNDS ARE NEEDED TO
COMPLETE. EASY PATH RELATED WORK
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THEY
CRITICIZE ADDITIONAL FUNDS BUT
ONLY AFTER RECEIVING. APPROVAL
FROM BOTH THE DIRECTOR OF
FINANCE AND THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE.
.
THE MAYOR OF MAYOR VISION ALSO
INCLUDES FIFTY FIVE MILLION FOR
GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION FOR
PSYCHIATRIC RESIDENTS.
FORTY MILLION WOULD BE.
PROVIDED FOR THE UC TO EXPAND
THEIR RESIDENCY PROGRAM SERVING
UNDERSERVED AND RURAL AREAS OF
THE STATE THAT DESPERATELY NEED
ADDITIONAL.
HOT PSYCHIATRISTS AND OTHER
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS.
FIFTEEN MILLION WOULD BE
ADMINISTERED BY THE UC AS A
STATEWIDE GRANT PROGRAM OPEN TO
ALL.
ACCREDITED RESIDENCY PROGRAMS
THAT SERVE UNDERSERVED RURAL
AREAS.
THESE FUNDS ARE INTENDED TO
SUPPORT RESIDENTS OF THE ENTIRE
TERM OF THEIR RESIDENCY.
AND AS SUCH WOULD BE MADE
AVAILABLE FOR FOR MULTIPLE
YEARS.
OTHER MAJOR REVISION ALSO
INCLUDES A ONE POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS FOR ANTI BIAS TRAINING
AT THE UC NC IS HERE TO COMBAT
THE RISING NUMBER OF HATE
INCIDENTS ON OUR UNIVERSITY
CAMPUSES. AND A MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE INSTITUTE ON GLOBAL
CONFLICT AND COOPERATION OUGHT
TO SUPPORT ITS RESEARCH
OPERATIONS.
DO YOU SEE THAT THE MIRROR
VISION ALSO INCLUDES LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD ALLOW THE DIRECTOR OF
FINANCE SHOULD THE UC RAISE
TUITION AND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
TO REDIRECT A CORRESPONDING
AMOUNT OF UC'S MAIN
APPROPRIATION TO SUPPORT CAL
GRANT COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH.
I END OF CLASS SCHOLARSHIP COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH A TUITION
INCREASE.
FINALLY THEM A REVISION
INCLUDES ONE HUNDRED MILLION ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA THEY
HAVE A A LARGE DEMONSTRATED
NEED.
AND WE FEEL THIS WOULD MAKE A
AYE AT A CRITICAL IMPACT ON THAT
NEED I'M WILLING TO TAKE
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU ALEJO JASON CONCENTRA
ROSOLINO.
I'LL BE WALKING YOU THROUGH
SEVERAL OF THE ITEMS THAT YOU
ARE BEFORE YOU TODAY ON AND TO
DO THAT I'LL BE WALKING THROUGH.
I REPORT THAT ON MY COLLEAGUE
EARLIER INTRODUCED YOU.
ON THIS FIRST ISSUE ALT
ALTERNATE AGENDA PAGE TWENTY
NINE THAT LISTS ALL OF THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION
PROPOSALS FOR YOU SEE AND
ASSOCIATED RECOMMENDATIONS.
FOR THE SAKE OF TIME ON A WALK
THROUGH OF WHAT WE THINK ARE
KIND OF THREE BIG ONES FOR YOU
YOU WERE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
RECOMMENDATIONS. THAT YOU SEE IN
THIS TABLE.
THE FIRST ALL WALK YOU THROUGH
IS THE REPERCUSSIONS OF FOR THE
TUITION INCREASE.
OUT WE UNDERSTAND THE GOVERNOR A
IN THIS PROPOSAL WHAT HE'S
TRYING TO DO IS LINK TUITION
DECISIONS IN GENERAL FUND
DECISIONS TOGETHER IT'S APPROACH
WE'VE. OURSELVES ONE RECOMMENDED
THE LEGISLATURE TAKE.
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE DOESN'T WANT TO
INCREASE TUITION AND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN
WE THINK SUCH LANGUAGE COULD BE
WARRANTED.
BUT WE ARE ACTION RECOMMEND
GOING EVEN FURTHER THAN IT DID
THE ADMINISTRATION THOUGH RATHER
THAN JUST THINKING OF A
REDUCTION INTO A GENERAL FUND TO
THE ASSOCIATED CAL GRANT NO
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP. A INCREASES
WE RECOMMEND YOU CONSIDER DOING
A DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR FOR ADOPTION
SO THE INC DISSOCIATED INCREASE
IN TUITION REVENUE YOU REDUCE
THE GENERAL FUND BY THAT AMOUNT.
THAT WOULD PROVIDE A STRONGER
INCENTIVE AND ALSO ENSURE THAT
ANY JEWISH INCREASES UNCOVERING
ANY OTHER COSTS THAT YOU HADN'T
HAD A. PRIORITIZE FOR THE
UNIVERSITY IN THAT YEAR.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT TO THE EXTENT
THAT TUITION IS OFF THE TABLE
FOR YOU THIS YEAR ANY OTHER
INCREASE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PROVIDE ABOVE THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET WHICH WOULD HAVE TO COME
FROM THE GENERAL FUND.
THE SECOND ISSUE OUR WE WANT TO
WALK YOU THROUGH AS TO ITS KIND
OF FIVE DOWN ON THAT TABLE THERE
TO PSYCHIATRIC RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS ISSUE. WE THINK THIS
ISSUE RAISES A LOT OF QUESTIONS
FOR THE LEGISLATURE. ALL THE
FIRST IS WHETHER OR NOT.
SAIKIA SITE YET A PSYCHIATRIC
PROGRAMS ARE THE HIGHEST
PRIORITY FOR YOU THIS YEAR.
OTHER CONCERNS THAT OF FROM MANY
DIFFERENT TYPES OF SPECIALTY
AREAS OF THEIR SHORTAGES BOTH
STATEWIDE IN REGIONALLY YOU FOR
THE PAST HEARD CONCERNS ABOUT
PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS FOR
EXAMPLE. SO THIS IS A QUESTION
FOR YOU WHETHER OR NOT THE
SPECIALTY AREA IS YOUR HIGHEST
PRIORITY.
TO THE EXTENT IT IS A THEN
RAISES QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT THE
UNDERLYING AYE IF YOU HEAR IS
WHAT MIGHT WE SEE THE SHORTAGES
RIGHT NOW THE ADMINISTRATION IS
ARGUING TO INCREASE OF MORE
SLOTS FOR RESIDENCY PROGRAMS.
BUT IN THE STATE IN THE PAST THE
STATUS TRIED OTHER AMOUNT
MECHANISMS TO SUCH AS LOAN
FORGIVENESS PROGRAMS RECRUITMENT
AND RETENTION PROGRAMS.
ALMOND SO THEY RAISE THE
QUESTION WHETHER OR NOT THIS IS
REALLY SORT OF THE BEST POLICY
LEVER THAT YOU HAVE IN PLACE.
AND THEN THE THIRD ISSUE IS
WHETHER OR NOT.
THAT TO THE EXTENT THAT THIS IS
A PIPELINE ISSUE IN THAT THEY'RE
MORE SPOTS THAT ARE NEEDED BY
THEIR NOT. A ONE TIME
AUGMENTATION IS REALLY THE BEST
SOLUTION HERE OR SOMETHING
ONGOING IS MORE WARRANTED.
NOT SO TO THE EXTENT THAT THIS
IS A PRIORITY FOR YOU THIS YEAR
INTO THE SEND THAT YOU FEEL LIKE
YOU'VE YOU CAN I GET A HANDLE ON
THIS BEFORE AND TIME FOR BUDGET
CLOSE OUT. WE DO SOME OTHER
SUGGESTIONS THAT THAT COULD
IMPROVE THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
ALL THE FIRST IS TO MAKE ALL THE
FUNDING COMPETITIVE CURRENTLY
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSING
TO GIVE FORTY TWO YOU SEE AND
FIFTEEN FOR GRANT PROGRAM. WE
THINK IT MAKES MORE SENSE TO
MAKE THE WHOLE OUTFIT FIFTH OF
FIFTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
PROGRAM COMPETITIVE GRANTS SO
THAT IT REALLY TARGETED TOWARDS
THOSE.
A PROGRAMS THAT ARE ADDRESSING
THE HIGHEST NEED.
SECONDLY WE ALSO RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDER A
ADMINISTRATE ADMINISTERING THIS
PROGRAM THROUGH AN INDEPENDENT
BODY RATHER THAN YOU SEE TO
ENSURE NO PREFERENCES GIVEN TO
YOU SEE PROGRAMS.
AND YOU COULD USE AN EXISTING
BODY FOR EXAMPLE THE STATE OF
THE OFFICE OF STATEWIDE HEALTH
PLANNING DEVELOPMENT.
ADMINISTERS A SUMMER PROGRAM FOR
PRIMARY CARE SO THAT'S ONE
PROGRAM YOU COULD CONSIDER.
WE ALSO RECOMMEND SOME
ADDITIONAL REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS AND THAT IT YOU
FURTHER CAPITA MINISTRY OF COST
WE THINK THE TEN PERCENT CAP IS
A BIT HIGH FIVE PERCENT OR SIX
PERCENT WOULD BE A MORE
REASONABLE.
AT PROGRAM.
THE FINAL THING I WOULD TOUCH ON
IN OUR CHART IS OF TOWARDS THE
BOTTOM YOU'LL SEE SOMETHING FOR
YOU SEE PATH OPERATIONS AND THIS
IS AN ISSUE THAT THIS COMMITTEE
DISCUSSED UP IN A PRIOR HEARING
AS YOU RECALL. A YOU SEE PATH IS
A PROJECT FROM THE UNIVERSITY TO
INTEGRATE ALL OF ITS HUMAN
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS INTO
ONE INTEGRATED SYSTEM.
AT A PRIOR SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN OF
THE PROGRAM IS FUNDED BY THE A
CHARGES ON THE CAMPUSES. IT
THOUGH PROGRAMS ROLLED INTO THE
USE YOUR P. LINE ITEM AND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN BY THE
LEGISLATURE.
I THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING TO BUDGET FOR THE
PROGRAM.
IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
WE ARE BOTH BY A COMBINATION OF
A LINE ITEM AND CAMPUS CHARGES
WE THINK THAT. A PROPOSALS OF
UNNECESSARILY COMPLEX
WE THINK A BETTER A MORE
RATIONAL APPROACH WOULD BE TO
JUST STICK WITH ONE EITHER A
LINE ITEM OR CAMPUS CHARGES.
AT THE MOMENT WE DO SEE SOME
ADVANTAGES TO IT GOING BACK TO A
USER FEE MODEL THE SYSTEM DOES
ON THE PROJECT SERVICE UPRIGHT
SERVICES TO CAMPUSES THE
CAMPUSES MIGHT BE. MORE
INCENTIVIZE TO INTERACT WITH
THAT PROGRAM AND RETIRED CONTROL
COSTS IF THEY'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR
MANAGING THE COST OF THE
PROGRAM.
REGARDLESS OF WHATEVER APPROACH
YOU TAKE WOULD YOU RECOMMEND A
RETHINKING THE STATE'S A SHARE
OF THE PROJECTS COSTS CURRENTLY
THE STATE PAYS FOR THE ENTIRE
PROJECT BUT THE PROJECT REALLY
SERVING PARA UNIVERSITY. OF NOT
JUST THE GENERAL CAMPUS BUT ALSO
THE HOSPITAL'S OTHER SORT OF
AUXILIARY SYSTEMS OF THE OF THE
ON.
OF THE SYSTEM SO WE RECOMMEND
ADOPTING A.
CENTER POLICY TO SHARE THE COST
BETWEEN OF THE STATE AND NON
STATE FUNCTIONS OF THE
UNIVERSITY WE HAVE A FEW
THOUGHTS ON THAT IF IF YOU'D
LIKE TO EXPORT THAT FURTHER.
WILL ALSO REMAIN CONCERNED OF
LONG TERM WITH THE PROJECT SORT
OF ESCALATING COSTS
RECOMMEND REGARDLESS OF WHATEVER
ACTION YOU TAKE BUT YOU CONTINUE
TO MONITOR THE PROGRAM
VIGOROUSLY CONTINUE TO HAVE
OVERSIGHT HEARINGS TO ENSURE
THAT. COSTS ARE JUSTIFIED AND
THAT THERE ARE SAVINGS ARE BEING
PRODUCED AS A RESULT OF THE
PROGRAM.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE ON THIS A
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU.
YOU SEE.
SAVOR TENANT OF THIS IS ON.
SAVOR ATTENDED UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA UP THINK YOU MISTER
TURNER MCCARTY AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
REGARDING THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE FUNDING WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL THE GOVERNOR FOR THESE
FUNDS ON HIS RECOGNITION BUT YOU
SEE STRUGGLING WITH MAINTENANCE
OF OUR AGING FACILITIES. THE
PROPOSED FUNDS WILL ALLOW
CAMPUSES TO ADDRESS THE MOST
CRITICAL OF OUR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE ISSUES INCLUDING
FAILING PLUMBING.
A LEAKING ROOFS AND OTHER MAJOR
SYSTEMS
THE EXACT ALLOCATION TO EACH
CAMPUS HAS NOT YET BEEN
DETERMINED BUT IN THE PAST WHEN
WE HAVE.
ALLOCATED DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
FUNDING TO CAMPUSES. OF WE
EXPECT THAT THE CAMPUS
ALLOCATION WILL BE BASED ON A
COMBINATION OF FACTORS.
INCLUDING THE SQUARE FOOTAGE OF
STATE ELIGIBLE SPACE AND THE
AVERAGE AGE OF THE A SQUARE
ESTATE ELIGIBLE SPEECH SPACE ON
EACH CAMPUS.
OF EACH CAMPUS WILL BE ASKED TO
SUBMIT THEIR HIGHEST PRIORITY
PROJECTS TO UC OP FOR THAT
ALLOCATION PROCESS SHOULD YOU
CHOOSE TO PROVIDE THESE FUNDS
YOU SEE WHICH. WE VERY MUCH
REQUEST THAT YOU DO OF WE HAVE
WE HAVE NEED FOR THOSE. OF. THE
SERGEANT HAS PASSED OUT A
HANDOUT.
AND ALL BE WALKING YOU THROUGH
THOSE THROUGH THIS FOR SOME OF
THE OTHER A GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS.
REGARDING THE BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE I WANTED TO PROVIDE
SOME CONTEXT FOR YOU. UC REGENTS
HAVE NOT YET DECIDED TO VOTE ON
THE TUITION INCREASE.
THEY'VE DELAYED THERE MAY OUGHT
TUITION INCREASE VOTE.
OF SO THAT WE COULD WORK WITH
THE LEGISLATURE FOR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING WE CONTINUE TO REQUEST
THE LEGISLATURE FOR SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN LIEU OF
TUITION AND STUDENT SERVICES FEE
BUYOUT.
WE HAVE PROPOSED A NET TUITION
INCREASE OF TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
EIGHT DOLLARS PER STUDENT AND AN
INCREASE OF FIFTY FOUR DOLLARS
ON THE STUDENT SERVICES FREE.
PER STUDENT.
I CALTRANS COVER TUITION
INCREASES FOR THE LOWEST INCOME
STUDENTS WHO QUALIFY FOR CAL
GRANT.
CURRENTLY ON THE EXPENDITURES
FOR INSTRUCTION YOU CAN SEE THAT
ON SLIGHT THREE OF YOUR DOC. A
CALTRANS COVER ABOUT TWO
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY
DOLLARS OF OUR PER STUDENT
EXPENDITURES FOR INSTRUCTION SO
THAT'S THE COMPONENT OF THE
GOVERNOR. A IS TRYING TO ADDRESS
WITH HIS BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE.
AND WE CONTINUE TO RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT THE LEGISLATURE
PROVIDE US WITH THE SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLARS SO THAT WE DON'T
HAVE TO INCREASE TUITION TO
COVER ANY OF OUR BASIC COSTS.
REGARDING THE GOVERNOR'S.
PROPOSAL FOR GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION WHICH IS SAME AS
MEDICAL RESIDENCY AS WE CONTINUE
TO REQUEST.
OF THAT THE FORTY MILLION THAT
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS BE
PROVIDED A TO SWAP OUT THE
DO. REVERSED THE PROP FIFTY SIX
SWAP THAT WAS PROVIDED IN.
THE CURRENT YEAR BUDGET AND
ONGOING SO WE'RE REQUESTING THAT
THE FORTY MILLION DOLLARS BE
PROVIDED TO YOU SEE ON AN
ONGOING BASIS.
.
PROVIDING THE FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO YOU SEE IT WILL ALLOW
US TO PROVIDE THE FIVE PROP
FIFTY SIX FUNDS OUT AS GRANTS
AROUND THE STATE FOR MEDICAL
RESIDENCIES AND UNDERSERVED
AREAS.
AS INTENDED BY THE VOTERS
APPROVE PROPOSITIONS.
IN ADDITION WE WELCOME THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED ONE TIME
INVESTMENT IN PSYCHIATRIC
RESIDENCIES FOR UNDERSERVED
RURAL AREAS.
GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION.
COSTS APPROXIMATELY HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS PER PRESS
AND MEDICAL RESIDENT AND
PSYCHIATRIC RESIDENCY IS ABOUT
FOUR YEARS LONG TO PROVIDE YOU
SOME. UP CONTEXT FOR THOSE
FUNDS.
YOU SEE HAS THE CAPACITY TO
CONDUCT A GRANT PROGRAM FIRST A
FOR A STATE WHERE GRANT PROGRAM.
OF USUALLY ARE APPROXIMATE GRANT
MANAGEMENT COSTS IS A ABOUT FIVE
PERCENT THE GOVERNOR HAS
GENEROUSLY PROVIDED US WITH A
TEN PERCENT GAP.
.
SOME OF THOSE FUNDS WOULD GO
TOWARDS ACTUALLY GETTING THE
PROGRAM STARTED AND HIRING UP
HIRING THE STAFF DOING PROGRAM
EVALUATION AND UP POSSIBLY AUDIT
AT THE END.
AND IT ALSO TAKES ABOUT A YEAR
TO OF RECEIVE APPROVAL FOR NEW
PSYCHIATRIC OR ANY MEDICAL
RESIDENCY UP SLOTS. FROM THEIR
CREDITING BODY SO IF THE
APPROVAL DOES NOT CURRENTLY
EXIST THERE MAY BE A DELAY. IN.
FILING THE APPLICATION AND
RECEIVING THAT APPROVAL TO THEFT
MAY CREATE SOME DELAYS. IN
GETTING A PROGRAM STARTED.
IN RECORDS TWO D. REDIRECTION
FOR ENROLLMENT GROWTH.
AB NINETY SEVEN THE BUDGET OCT
TWENTY SEVENTEEN STATED THAT UC
SHOULD FIND FUNDING FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT AND OTHER
SOURCES TO FUND FIFTEEN HUNDRED
NEW CALIFORNIA RESIDENT
STUDENTS.
DURING THIS LAST FALL UC OP MET
WITH.
MULTIPLE LEGISLATIVE STAFF
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS WELL.
TO EXAMINE WHICH OF UC OPIES
PROGRAMS COULD BE UP SELECTED
FOR REDIRECTION.
THE ITEM IN FRONT OF YOU TODAY
AS PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR IS
THE RESULT OF THAT DISCUSSION TO
PROVIDE THE FUNDS THE CAMPUSES.
FOR FUNDING THOSE STUDENTS SO
WE WE REQUEST APPROVAL.
.
SEEM.
WE'RE ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S ANTI BIAS TRAINING
AND CENTER FOR GLOBAL CONFLICT
AND COOPERATION.
LET ME MOVE ON TO SLIGHT.
OF FIVE
WHICH DEALS WITH YOU SEE PASS
THAT THE MORE SIDE MORE
COMPLICATED ISSUE.
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WOULD
ALLOW US TO COVER ALL OF THE
OPERATIONAL COSTS FOR YOU SEE
PATH.
A IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND WE'RE
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT
OF WITHOUT THESE SUFFICIENT
FUNDING TO COVER THE COST FOR
YOU SEE PAST WE WOULD BE. STUCK
WITH COVERING TO.
OF WILL BE.
WE WOULD HAVE TO COVER THE
OPERATIONAL COSTS BOARD BOTH UC
PATH AND SOME OF THE CAMPUS
LEGACY SYSTEMS WHICH ARE. A VERY
OLD AND IN DANGER OF FAILING.
UC POTS WILL ALLOW US TO. A
CREATE.
STANDARD BEST A BUSINESS SYSTEMS
ACROSS THE UNIVERSITY CAMPUSES.
AND THUS ARM ALSO ALLOW FOR
EASIER.
.
DATA ANALYSIS AND OF MANY OF THE
OTHER THINGS THAT.
.
OF.
WILL BE BENEFICIAL.
SO SLIDES FIVE SHOWS YOU THE
DEPLOYMENT SEQUENCE FOR YOU SEE
PAST THAT OF WE ARE PROPOSING AT
THIS POINT.
I'M GETTING THE UP ADDITIONAL
FUNDS AS PROPOSED BY THE
GOVERNOR WILL ALLOW US TO.
CONTINUE ON SCHEDULE AND BRING
TO ADDITIONAL CAMPUSES ON.
ON TO THE UC PASSED SYSTEM.
SLIDE SIX SHOWS HOW WE INTEND
TO SPEND THOSE FUNDS AND THE
VARIOUS CATEGORIES.
FOR OF THE EXPENDITURES WITHIN
THE UC PATH.
I'M.
AND.
THEN.
.
LIKE I STATED PREVIOUSLY IF WE
DON'T GET THE ADDITIONAL FUNDS
AS PROPOSED.
BY THE GOVERNOR THROUGH THE
ASSESSMENT.
WE WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO BRING
ON THOSE ADDITIONAL CAMPUSES.
ON THE UC PATH AND.
THERE WOULD BE AN INVESTMENT
THAT.
OF.
WOULD NOT BE.
FULLY UTILIZED BECAUSE WE'VE
BEEN BUILDING UP TO TOWARD THIS.
IT'S WE'RE HOPING FOR APPROVAL
FROM THE LEGISLATURE ON THAT
ITEM AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
OKAY THANK YOU ALL OF I HAVE A
QUESTION A NOT FOR BURKE FOR YOU
SEE I KNOW WE HAD. A LENGTHY
HEARING A FEW.
MONTHS AGO ON ON THE THESE
ISSUES AND WE'LL COME BACK WITH
OUR PLAN IT IN THAT IN A FEW
DAYS I DO WONDER BAD AND THEY
WERE IN HERE ABOUT THE PUBLIC
COMMENT I'M SURE TO.
FOR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON AND
THE.
FRANKLY IT'S NOT REALLY THAT
YOU SEE ISSUE BUT AS YOU SEE IT
THAT THE HEALTH ISSUE THE
GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION THE
PROP FIFTY SIX.
AND THE DISAPPOINTMENT THAT IT
IS NOT FULLY FUNDED.
IN THE BUDGET BUT THEY DO HAVE
THAT THEIR PROPOSAL FOR ROUGHLY
THE SAME AMOUNT OF MONEY.
FOR MEDICAL EDUCATION ALBEIT
FOR.
.
PACIFIC COHORT.
WHY DIDN'T DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IT KNOWING THAT THERE'S
SO MUCH?
AND ANGST ABOUT THE PROP FIFTY
SIX.
PLAN LAST YEAR AND A HALF IN THE
BUDGET.
TAKE THAT SAME AMOUNT OF MONEY
AND.
.
BASICALLY FOLLOW UP WITH THAT
COMMITMENT THAT THE VOTERS MAY
WHEN THEY VOTED FOR PROPERTY
SIX.
I'M MISTER GRAY CHU REASONS I'VE
FIRST THIS PROPOSAL FOR
PSYCHIATRIC MEDICAL.
GREATER MEDICAL EDUCATION IS
ONE TIME.
WE HAVE.
JET YOU WERE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE STATE'S LONG TERM FISCAL
HEALTH. WE HAVE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE IN THIS FISCAL YEAR
THAT CAN SUPPORT THIS.
AS OPPOSED TO.
.
UNDOING THE HAVE THE FUN SHIFT
FOR PROP FIFTY SIX THAT WOULD BE
AN ONGOING SPENDING COMMITMENT.
SECOND THIS IS PART OF A A
LARGER MENTAL HEALTH AND
HOMELESSNESS PACKAGE.
THAT.
WE'RE COLLABORATING WITH OUR
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
COLLEAGUES ON.
I GET THAT BUT. DO YOU DISAGREE.
THAT.
.
THAT THAT THE PROP FIFTY SIX AND
THEN PROMISED. TO THE ELECTORATE
VOTED FOR IT WAS TO HAVE.
AN ADDITIONAL FIFTEEN MILLION
FOR GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION
NOT SUPPLANT.
ARE WE BELIEVE THAT'S.
THE FUN SHIP THAT'S REFLECTED
IN BOTH THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL AND THE MAYOR EFFICIENT
AS A REASON LISA FUNDS AND IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE LANGUAGE
PROPERTY SEX.
OKAY FAIR ENOUGH.
ALRIGHTY THANK YOU. NEXT WILL
PROCEEDS.
WITH ISSUE NUMBER FIVE.
IS THAT I REQUEST THAT THE
COMMITTEE CONSIDER.
ARE THEY HERE.
SO.
KIM S..
I REQUEST
A COMMITTEE BROWN ASKED ME THREE
TO NINETY NINE.
FOR.
LANGUAGE IN THE BUDGET RELATED
TO VEHICLE EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY DATA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OUT
FIRST LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
AGENDA I THINK THIS ITEM AS YOU
ARE AWARE LAST WEEK PASSED ME
THIRTY TO NINETY NINE MEMBERS
WENT ON STRIKE.
WELL WE DID RECEIVE SUBSTANTIAL
NEWS COVERAGE WE'RE VERY
FRUSTRATED THAT MEDIA FAILED TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT AFRICAN AMERICAN
AND LATINO WOMEN. ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY UNDERPAID AT THE
UNIVERSITY.
FOR EXAMPLE IT TAKES AN AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMAN SEVEN YEARS TO
REACH THE STARTING SALARY OF A
WHITE MALE COLLEAGUES.
FOR LATINA IT TAKES SIX YEARS TO
MEET THE STARTING SALARY OF A
WHITE MALE COUNTERPARTS.
THIS BEGS THE QUESTION WHY IS
THIS HAPPENING.
WHITE MEN ARE HIRED INTO HIGHER
CLASSIFICATIONS TO BEGIN WITH.
WHAT WE'RE ATTEMPTING TO DO IS
CRANE CENTER FOR THE UNIVERSITY
TO ADDRESS THIS WIDENING GENDER
AND RACIAL AND EQUITY?
THIS ISSUE WAS FURTHER
EXACERBATED BY THE UNIVERSITY'S
PRACTICE TO MOVE THE SAME JOBS
INTO CONTRACTED PHYSICIANS WHERE
EMPLOYEES ARE PAID.
EVEN LESS AND ARE NOT PROVIDED
STABILITY.
A UNIVERSITY EMPLOYMENT. NINETY.
THIS SHIP TO THE DISGRACE A
WALMART REDOING IT WOULD NOT BE
TOLERATED. THE UNIVERSITY HIRES
A CONTRACTOR THAT GROWS THIS
DISPARITY THERE SHOULD BE
CONSEQUENCE
WE APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF THIS LANGUAGE INCLUSION AND
LOOK FOR TO GAIN YOUR SUPPORT
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU FOR THE PRESENTATION I
DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
YES MISTER ABOUT.
JUST A QUICK QUESTION.
YOU'RE SAYING THAT.
WHITE MEN ARE HIRED AND AT A
HIGHER CLASSIFICATION.
COULD YOU DEFINE WHAT THE
CLASSIFICATIONS ARE I'M NOT SURE
OF THAT STRUCTURE.
SO FOR PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
TRADITIONALLY IF THERE'S
DIFFERENT.
.
THERE'S A SCALE WHERE YOU CAN
EAT I'M HIRED AT SO THE USUALLY
GO UP TO ABOUT A NINE.
SO.
WITHOUT RAISING ANY CONCERN YOU
COULD ENTER AT AT STEP ONE UP
THERE WITH STEP FOR. BEYOND THAT
IT REQUIRES PROPER JUSTIFICATION
FOR WHAT'S HAPPENING AT THE
STARTING SALARY OF WHITE MEN
STARTS AT A HIGHER LEVEL WITHIN
THAT CATHOLIC KITCHEN WHEREAS
MINORITY WOMEN ARE STARTING AT
STEP ONE. MIGHT FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONNAIRE IS IS THAT FOR THE
SAME JOB
SAME GOT OKAY THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH WILL
CONSIDER THAT'S WHEN WE ARE.
COME UP WITH OUR FINAL PLAN
NEXT WEEK.
ALRIGHT WE'RE GONNA PROCEED
NOTION NUMBER SIX.
CSU
.
DAN HAD OUR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
ALSO WITH A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
THE PROPOSALS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET FOR TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET REPOSE AT
THIS YEAR'S YOU RECEIVE A BASE
INCREASE OF NINETY TWO POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS.
AN ONGOING GENERAL FUND SUPPORT.
WHICH IS THE SAME INCREASE
PROPOSED FOR THE SEA IS THAT THE
UC.
THIS APPROACH INCREASES A FOR
THE UC FOR THE CSU IS CONSISTENT
PAST PRACTICE.
THIS WILL PROVIDE THE CSU AT
JUST OVER THREE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN STATE GENERAL
FUND FOR TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN.
THE MAYOR VISION INCLUDES A FEW
NEW PROPOSALS FOR THE CSU.
FIRST THE MAYOR VISION INCLUDES
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
AUTHORIZE THE DIRECTOR OF
FINANCE.
OFFSET THE SEATS USE MAIN ITEM
BY THE AMOUNT OF ESTIMATE THE
CAL GRANT CAL GRANT PROGRAM IN
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM
COSTS.
BECAUSE BY SYSTEM MY TUITION
INCREASE IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN.
THIS IS THE CORRESPONDING TO
PROPOSAL TO WHAT WAS MENTIONED
IN THE UC DISCUSSION.
CHRIS LANGUAGE SIMPLY REFLECTS
THE COST INCURRED BY THE STATE.
BY THE STATE'S FINANCIAL AID
PROGRAMS THAT ARE OFTEN NOT
CONSIDERED WHEN TUITION RISES.
THE MAYOR VISION ALSO INCREASES
THE AUGMENTATION THE CAPITAL
FLOWS PROGRAM.
A PROPOSED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET BY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND TO REFLECT A CHANGE
IN THE COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT
FROM TWO POINT FIVE ONE.
A TWO POINT SEVEN ONE PERCENT.
FINALLY THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING TO INCLUDE ONE HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ONE
TIME FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
PROJECTS
ACROSS THE SYSTEM.
THIS FUNDING WILL BE INCLUDED IN
THE CONTROL SECTION SUMMER TO
HELP AFTER DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
WAS FUNDED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN.
AND WITH THAT IF YOU HAVE AN
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE
FOR ME.
LEO A AGAIN ARE.
IF YOU GOT OUR TABLE ON PAGE
TWENTY SIX THAT LISTS ALL THE
MAY REVISION PROPOSALS FOR.
.
SEE IF YOU IN THAT'S THAT'S OUR
LA OR REPORT THAT I'M
REFERENCING THEIR.
I'LL JUST TOUCH ON THE FIRST TWO
ISSUES OPPOSITE OF TIME AND
THERE. OF VIRTUALLY IDENTICAL TO
YOU SEE.
SO OUR OUR MESSAGES STILL STAND
THERE ON THE REAP REPERCUSSIONS
FOR THE TUITION INCREASE THE
ONLY THING WE WOULD KNOW AS
EXISTING LAW ALREADY.
CONSTRAINTS USE YOU ABILITY TO
USE USE ABILITY TO INCREASE
TUITION IN NINETEEN NINETEEN.
SUCH THAT WE'RE NOT SURE THAT
THAT LANGUAGE IS IT'S QUITE IS
NEEDED FOR A AND THE CASES USE
YOU AS IT IS FOR YOU SEE.
ON THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
PROPOSAL.
A WE RECOMMEND YOU ADOPT THE
FUNDING LEVEL AND SEE IF SHE WAS
IS A BIT FARTHER ALONG THAN YOU
SEE UNDERSTANDING ITS
MAINTENANCE NEEDS OF KNOWS THAT
AS A TWO POINT SEVEN MEG BILLION
DOLLAR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
BACKLOG. ALSO KNOWS IT NEEDS TO
SPEND ABOUT A HUNDRED FORTY
MILLION ANNUALLY TO PREVENT THAT
BACKLOG FROM GOING FURTHER
THERE'LL FURTHER ALONG. OF WE DO
RECOMMEND IN ADDITION TO
ADOPTING THE FUNDING IF YOU
FIRST RECOMMEND THIS MANY TIMES
THAT YOU ATTACH A LITTLE REPORT
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS THAT
FUNDING THAT THEY. COME BACK TO
WITH A BROADER PLAN TO.
OF PICKED ON THAT DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG OVERTIME AND
IDENTIFY WHAT IT WASTE IMPROVE
MAINTENANCE PRACTICE OF SUCH
THAT. OF THE BACKLOG DOESN'T
REEMERGE OR THERE'S THERE ISN'T
ANY BACKLOG.
THANK YOU.
A RHINESTONE MISSY ISSUE I'D
LIKE TO POINT.
TALK ABOUT THE MOST OBVIOUS
THING OF THE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME FUNDS GRATEFUL
TO THE ADMINISTRATION.
FOR PROVIDING THOSE FUNDS AND
IT'S A GOOD STEP FORWARD IN
HELPING ADDRESS OUR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE
ONE THING THAT MY COLLEAGUES
FROM FINANCING ELIO I DO NOT
REYES WAS THE ISSUE OF ON GOING
SUPPORT FOR THE UNIVERSITY.
AS SOON AS. MY COLLEAGUE. DAN
HAD OUR FROM FINANCE MENTIONED
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED NINETY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS AND THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
MAY REVISION HAD NO RECURRING
CHANGE TO THAT.
AND SO WE STILL ARE LEFT WITH A
ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE MILLION
DOLLAR SHORTFALL.
IN OUR BUDGET REQUEST TO YOU.
AND THAT I SHORTFALL.
.
IF IT'S FILLED WOULD WOULD HELP
METER MANDATORY HEALTH CARE COST
INCREASES IN A MODEST LEVEL OF
ENROLLMENT GROWTH AND
BROUGH OF OTHER THINGS INCLUDING
INVESTING A GREAT INITIATIVE.
A SO WITH THE TUITION.
WITH THE TUITION INCREASE OFF
THE TABLE AS AS DECIDED ABOUT.
A MIDDLE OF APRIL.
IT ADDITIONAL ONGOING FUNDING
FROM THE STATE IS EVEN MORE
CRITICAL.
A AND WITHOUT SUFFICIENT FUNDING
FROM THE STATE UNIVERSAL NEED TO
MAKE A DIFFICULT DECISIONS THAT
WOULD SLOW THE. UNIVERSITY WIDE
PROGRESS THAT WE'VE MADE INSTANT
SUCCESS AND ACHIEVEMENT. SO ARE
PRIORITIZING ADEQUATE FUNDING OF
FOR THIS ISSUE WE BELIEVE IS KEY
TO CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE THANKS
FOR THE COMP PREVENT OPPORTUNITY
SPEAK.
THANK YOU.
VOEPEL.
NO.
I THINK IT SAYS.
A VERY BRIEF PROPOSAL HENCE
THAT'S WHY MISTER MEDINA'S.
ONE FLOOR BELOW US AND WATCHING
HIM ON FACEBOOK LIFE USE THEM.
PRESS EVENT TALKING ABOUT THE
CSU BUDGET SO WE WILL ON.
HAVE A HAVE.
RESPONSE TO THIS NEXT WEEK NO
QUESTIONS.
ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN.
CALIFORNIA STATE LIBRARY.
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE PROPOSED.
WE HAVE ALWAYS.
BY ITS GO AHEAD.
AGAIN DAN HAD OUR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE
THE MINISTRATION PROPOSES THIRTY
SEVEN POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND SUPPORT
FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE LIBRARY
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
THIS INCLUDES FIVE PROPOSALS IN
THE NAY REVISION.
THESE PROPOSALS TOTAL ONE POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS WITH ONE
MILLION OF THAT IS ONGOING
FUNDING.
IN LATE FEBRUARY HUNDREDS OF
BOOKS IN THE STATE LOTTERIES
COLLECTION WERE DAMAGED BY HEAVY
RAINS.
THEN A REVISION INCLUDE SEVERAL
MEASURES TO ADDRESS THIS.
THE ADMINISTRATION OPPOSES
SPENDING SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS
TO INSTALL FAULT THAT WOULD
PROTECT PART OF THE LIBRARY'S
COLLECTION.
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS TO REPAIR
DAMAGE BOOKS
AND THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
PURCHASE EMERGENCY SUPPLIES ALL
WHICH IS ONE TIME GENERAL FUND.
ADDITIONALLY DOT THE DEPARTMENT
OF GENERAL SERVICES OFTEN AS DID
YES HAS AGREED TO A PARENT THE
LIBRARIES DAMAGE REFUSING
EXISTING FUNDS IN ITS BUDGET.
AND FURTHER THE ADMINISTRATION
IS INCLUDED ROUGHLY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND FOR ONE
TIME DEFERRED MAINTENANCE IN A
CONTROLLED SECTION UNDER DID
YES.
THE MAYOR VISION INCLUDES FOUR
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON GOING GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT THE CALIFORNIA NEWSPAPER
PROJECT.
THIS PROGRAM LOCATED AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
RIVERSIDE.
WORKS TO COLLECT AND PRESERVE
HISTORIC NEWSPAPERS FROM EACH
COUNTY IN CALIFORNIA.
THE MAYOR VISION ALSO INCLUDES
THREE HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS ONGOING GENERAL FUND.
TO ACCOUNT FOR BRENT INC A RANK
COST CHARGE BY DID YES.
FOR USE OF TWO BUILDINGS AND
CENTRAL PLANT FACILITY CHARGES.
THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES TO
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND OF WHICH
EIGHTY THOUSAND IS ONGOING.
PROVIDE NEW INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SECURITY EQUIPMENT
AND SUBSCRIPTION SERVICES FOR
THE STATE LIBRARY.
THIS IS IN RESPONSE TO AN
ANALYSIS BY THE CALIFORNIA
MILITARY DEPARTMENT WHICH
IDENTIFIED SEVERAL
VULNERABILITIES IN THE STATE
LIBRARY'S LIKE HE'S.
FINALLY THE MAYOR VISION
INCLUDES FUNDING FOR TWO DIGITAL
PRESERVATION PROPOSALS.
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS ONGOING GENERAL FUND
WILL BE USED TO PERFORM
QUARTERLY WEB CROSS.
STATE GOVERNMENT WEB PAGES TO
CREATE A DIGITAL RECORD.
AT SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
JET ONGOING GENERAL FUND WERE
USED TO PURCHASE DIGITAL
STORAGE.
WITH THAT I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE FOR ME.
OKAY GREAT AND YOUR PROPOSALS
ARE LISTED ON PAGE FOURTEEN OF
YOUR AGENDA WHEN IT'S ON A
REPORTS ALL JUST WORK FROM YOUR
AGENDA.
AS YOU CAN SEE IN YOUR GENDER
THEIR FIVE PROPOSALS A TO HIS
PROPOSED TO HIS PROPOSALS WE
DON'T HAVE CONCERNS WITH ITS ALL
JUST TOUCH ON THE THREE THAT WE
DO HAVE. ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
ABOUT
A BECAUSE OF THE TIMING WITH
BERMAN RECEIVE THESE PROPOSALS
REQUIRE THE ADMINISTRATION
WASN'T ABLE TO ANSWER ALL OF OUR
QUESTIONS SO. WE DO HAVE A FEW
CONCERNS WE JUST WANTED A LIST
FOR THE COMMITTEE.
THE FIRST UP WOULD BE THE
COLLECTION PROTECTION ACTIVITIES
A AS THE AS FINANCE NOTED MOST
OF THE FUNDING WOULD BE FOR. A
NEW VAULT THE REMAINING FUNDING
WOULD BE TO REPAIR BOOKS
AND I'D I'D DEVELOP AN EMERGENCY
SUPPLY KIT ON THAT'S IN RESPONSE
TO.
LOVE FLOODING YOUR ROOF LEAK
THAT HAPPENED BACK IN. MARCH.
I WE THINK THE THE ARE WRITTEN
PREPARE FOR THE BOOKS IN THE
EMERGENCY SUPPLY KIT IS
WARRANTED GIVEN THE DAMAGE ON
THOSE BOOKS.
ON THE VAULT WE WERE LESS CLEAR
ON THE NEED FOR THAT GIVEN THAT
OF THE ROOF IS LEADERS CURRENTLY
BEING A REPAIRED AND THERE MIGHT
BE ADDITIONAL. DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE FUNDING ALSO IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
FOR ADDITIONAL DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE SO WE THOUGHT THE
FIRST PARTY SHOULD BE ON A
ENSURING THAT THE THE STRUCTURE
OF THE FACILITY IS IN GOOD
CONDITION ADDRESSING THOSE
ISSUES FIRST BEFORE AND SELLING
OF OCT.
WELL THAT WAS OUR CONCERN THERE.
ON THE SECRETARY WITH CONCERN
THE CALIFORNIA NEWSPAPER PROJECT
THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT THE STATE
FUNDED.
OF SEVERAL YEARS AGO IN THE
EARLY TWO THOUSANDS THE FUNDING
LEVEL FROM THE STATE SIDE WAS A
A FEW HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
CAN.
I CURRENTLY THE PROGRAM IS A
RECEIVING STATE FUNDING AND IT
REPORTS THAT IT'S RECEIVING
FEDERAL DOLLARS ACCORDING TO THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT THE GOAL
HERE IS TO SUPPLANT THAT FEDERAL
FUNDING. A WITH STATE FUNDING
AND THEN TO PROVIDE AN
ADDITIONAL AUGMENTATION OF THE
ARGUMENT IS THAT THE STATE
FUNDING IS.
JUST MORE STABLE AND LESS
VOLATILE THAN THE FEDERAL
FUNDING LIMITATION HOUSING
PROVIDED US A MORE CLEAR BUDGET
INFORMATION TO DETERMINE OF ALL
TOLD US FOR A FUNDING SOURCES.
AND I ITS ORMAN'S IN COURT
WHETHER NOT FEDERAL FUNDS COULD
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE PROGRAM.
SO WE RECOMMEND TO THE EXTENT
THAT FEDERAL FUNDS ARE STILL
AVAILABLE FOR THE PROGRAM THAT
YOU REJECT THIS PROPOSAL.
FINALLY ON THE.
DIGITAL PRESERVATION ACTIVITIES
ON PAGE FIFTEEN OF YOUR AGENDA
OTHER TO PROPOSALS HERE ONCE FOR
THE HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR PRESERVING STATE
GOVERNMENT WEBSITES.
OH WE JUST HAD ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS ON THIS.
PROPOSAL IT.
WHICH WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
PURPOSE IS TO STE IS TO PRESERVE
GOVERNMENT WEBSITES AT A POINT
IN TIME. ARE MEANT TO DO THAT
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR WE JUST HAVE
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS ABOUT WHICH
AGENCIES.
.
I WENT WHICH POINT IN TIME HOW
THEY MAKE THESE DETERMINATIONS
WHY IS THIS A PRIORITY VERSUS
SAYING PRESERVING. ALL THAT DATA
OR THE OTHER CONTENT THAT MIGHT
BE AVAILABLE THOSE WEBSITES WE
RECOMMEND YOU ASKED THOSE
QUESTIONS AND A LITTLE MORE
INFORMATION ON IT.
ON THE SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR THE. PRESERVATION
SORTS OF CAPTIONS
THE ADMINISTRATION ARE PROVIDED
US SOME CONFUSING INFORMATION
HERE OF THE ADMINISTRATION NOTED
THAT THE STATE LIBRARY
CURRENTLY.
PAYS A THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
TERABYTE FOR.
AT ITS CAPACITY A DIGITAL
CAPACITY NEEDS AND CURRENTLY HAS
FIFTY TERABYTES SORT SPEND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND IT'S ASKING FOR SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR SEVENTY
FIVE TERABYTES IN THAT METHOD
MAKES SENSE TO US IT SEEMS LIKE
IT SHOULD BE TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS WE RECOMMEND
YOU GET MORE INFORMATION ON THAT
MORE CLARITY FROM THAT. ENOUGH
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION FROM THE
STATE LIBRARY TO THE EXTENT THAT
THEY CAN'T EXPLAIN THAT WE
RECOMMEND PROVIDING TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS INSTEAD OF THE
FULL SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND.
THANK YOU.
VERY WELL.
KEEPING TRACK OF THE DETAILS
EXCELLENT.
AND THAT TAKES US.
LITTLE STATE LIBRARY.
AND SO WE ARE THANKFUL TO THE
GOVERNOR TO.
S. ONE FORWARD AND WE SUPPORT.
THESE WERE.
NOW WE'RE ON ISSUE EIGHT.
THANK YOU
.
GOOD MORNING SHOW CAST OF THE
SERVICE EMPLACEMENT SHOW UNION.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT TODAY. ON THE ANALYSIS
DISTINCTLY.
DESCRIBES A PROPOSAL AND IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME I WILL BE VERY
BRIEF.
THE PROPOSAL SIMPLY TO
ELIMINATE A SUNSET OF EXISTING
LAW OF IT VERY NARROWLY AND
DISCREETLY CRAFTED LAW. THAT'S
IN PLACE SINCE TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN. THE LAW ONLY DEALS WITH
WHEN A LIBRARY.
PACKED WITH A FOR PROFIT
COMPANY.
THIS LAW HAS BEEN WORKING VERY
WELL SINCE TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
AND HAS BEEN INSTRUMENTAL
PROTECTING TAX DOLLARS.
IT ALSO ENSURES THAT THE
LIBRARY.
SYSTEM AND WORK IS CONNECTED TO
COMMUNITY AND NOT A COMPACT
COMMODITY.
WE BELIEVE THE LIBRARY SERVICE
SHOULD NOT BE COVERED BY A
PROFIT MARGIN. AND THAT THIS
PROPOSAL WILL IN FACT ENSURE
THAT.
.
IT THAT ELIMINATING THE SENSIBLE
FACT ENSURE THAT OUR FREE
LIBRARY SYSTEM IN FACT REMAINS
FREE FOR ALL WHO USE IT. ON WE
ASK FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
THAT BRINGS US TO ISSUE NINE.
JEFF WHAT PART FINANCE UP THE
MIRAGE CONTAINS TWO PROPOSALS
RELATING HE'S HE HASTINGS
COLLEGE OF LAW.
THE FIRST IS ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT.
THE IDC HASTINGS I EFFORTS TO
IMPLEMENT THE UC PATH PROJECT ON
ITS CAMPUS.
AND THE SECOND IS ONE MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ONE TIME
FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AT THE
CAMPUS.
ABOUT OPEN ANY QUESTIONS.
BUT PAGE SEVENTEEN OF YOUR
AGENDA LISTS THE TWO PROPOSALS
JUST FOR YOUR BENEFIT O. TIENEN
OUR REPORTS ALL THIS WORK FROM
YOUR AGENDA.
WE HAVE CONCERNS OF BOTH PUZZLES
AND I WANT TO WALK THROUGH THEM
WITH THE COMMITTEE.
ON THE FIRST ISSUE OF THE ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL BACKGROUND.
BUT HE'S THINGS IS REPORTING
THAT IT IS IN THE PROCESS OF.
.
ALIGNING ITS HUMAN RESOURCES
PROCESSES WITH A THE UC PATH
SYSTEM THAT WAS DISCUSSED IN A
PREVIOUS ITEM. YOU SEE CURRENTLY
USES UC'S EXISTING LEGACY SYSTEM
USES IT BURT AND HEADING TO
RETIRE THE LEGACY SYSTEM AROUND
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT HE SINGS
HOUSE TO WORK TO IMPROVE IT TO.
ALIGN ITS CURRENT PROCESSES
WITH THE NEW SYSTEM.
A HASTINGS OF AND IT ARGUES THAT
BECAUSE IT'S SOMEWHAT DIFFERENT
FROM THE OTHER UC CAMPUSES IT
HAS A LOT MORE WORK TO DO THAN
THE OTHER A UC CAMPUSES SUCH
THAT. ON ME REQUIRES
SORT OF ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD THAT
MAYBE A TYPICAL CAMPUS MIGHT.
AND.
AS A RESULT THEY'RE ASKING FOR
AN AUGMENTATION TO WORK TO THAT.
.
YEAH ALIGNMENT MOST ABOUT
FUNDING WOULD BE FOR OF
CONSULTANTS OBSERVE MANAGE THAT
AND AS WELL AS ADDITIONAL
FUNDING LARGELY FOR ADDITIONAL
TIME TO TO WORK TOWARDS THAT.
WE TO OUR CONCERN HERE IS THAT
YOU'RE RECEIVING THIS TO A CLOSE
THE BUDGET CLOSE OUT EASY PATH
WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS
INITIALLY.
DISCUSSED IN TWENTY ELEVEN BY
THE UNIVERSITY HAS BEEN PLANNING
THIS FOR SEVERAL YEARS WE
QUESTION WHY THE LAW SCHOOL
DIDN'T PLAN FOR THE SOONER.
AND MORE GRADUALLY AND WHITES
COMING TO THE STATE NOW OF SOAP.
SO CLOSE TO THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF YOU SEE PATH WILL ALSO
QUESTION WHY DIDN'T COME TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN JANUARY OF THIS
YEAR.
.
TO THE EXTENT THAT THIS WAS SUCH
AS TO NOTABLE CHALLENGE AND
WHITES COMING SO CLOSE THE
BUDGET BECAUSE THAT'S WE
RECOMMEND YOU YOU GET CLARITY ON
THOSE TWO ISSUES.
AND I THINK THAT THEY'RE NOT
SATISFIED BY CLARITY REJECT THIS
PROPOSAL.
ON THE SECOND ISSUE FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE OUR CONCERN HERE IS
THAT THE LAW SCHOOL HASN'T YET
SUBMITTED A LIST OF PROJECTS
THAT WOULD LIKE TO.
USE THE FUNDING FOR.
AND WE THINK OF THE LIST IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT FOR
HASTINGS BECAUSE WE'RE NOT WHERE
THERE IS A CURRENT SIZE OF ITS
BACKLOGS IS UNKNOWN.
ON UNLIKE UC AND CSU HASTINGS IS
A RELATIVELY SMALLER US SCHOOL
HAS TO FACILITIES BASICALLY OR
ONE OF THE FACILITIES IS
SCHEDULED TO BE REPLACED BY A
NEW FACILITY. ARE AROUND TWENTY
NINETEEN AND THE SECOND FACILITY
ARE RECEIVED SOME ADDITIONAL
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE FUNDING IN
STE ONE TWENTY SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN.
ALSO THE EXTENT OF ITS DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG IS NOT WELL
KNOWN TO US RECOMMEND YOU GET
THAT WAS BEFORE PROVIDING ANY A
ONE TIME FUNDING FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE TO LAW SCHOOL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MAY BE ABLE GET SOME
CLARITY WITH HASTINGS COLLEGE OF
LAW.
YES MY NAME IS DAVID SEWARD AND
CHIEF FINANCIAL OFFICER I'M
ACCOMPANIED BY OUR ACADEMIC DEAN
OF MORSE RATNER.
IN TERMS OF THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE NEEDS.
THE COLLEGE IS IS A MUCH SMALLER
IN SCALE THAN YOU SEE OR CSU.
WE WILL BE TO BUT PROVIDE THAT
LIST PREFERRED WITH TO.
EQUIREMENTS OF SECTION FIX TO
THE PUBLIC FINANCE.
ON THAT LIST WE HAVE SOME
CRITICAL NEEDS OF PRIMARILY
RELATED TO.
AS THE NEED TO UPGRADE OUR
CLOSED CIRCUIT TV SYSTEM FOR
OUTSIDE.
COVERAGES.
THEY NEED TO OF ACHIEVE CHO
COMPLIANCE FOR DUCT WORK AN
EIGHT TRACK.
ALSO.
RENOVATING UPGRADE RESTROOMS.
I WE HAVE.
THIS AUGMENTATION IS SIGNIFICANT
FOR HASTINGS.
NOT A DROP IN THE BUCKET FOR
HASTINGS IT WILL ALLOW US TO.
MAKE SIGNIFICANT STRIDES ARE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND ADDRESS
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT ITEMS HAIR
AFTER THIS ALLOCATION WILL BE
LOOKING AT.
A OUTSTANDING ITEMS SUCH AS.
AFTER THIS ALLOCATION NEW
CARPETING PAINTING ELEVATOR
UPGRADES.
WHICH YEARS LOWER PRIORITY THAN
THE FIRE LIFE SAFETY AND THE.
THAT SECURITY ELEMENTS
SO WILL BE PROVIDING THAT LIST
WE'RE HAPPY TO SHARE IT AND THE
DISCUSS IT FURTHER IF THERE'S
ANY INTEREST.
IN TERMS OF YOU SEE PATH.
A THE PROJECTS BEEN GOING HAND
FITS TWENTY TEN TWENTY ELEVEN
HAS BEEN CHARACTERIZED BY STARTS
AND STOPS.
WITH THE LEVEL OF SCRUTINY IN
INTEREST OF BEING DEDICATED TO
PROJECT BY THE THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE.
THE.
.
PROJECT IMPLEMENTATION HAS BEEN
RAMPED UP THIS CAUGHT US OFF
CYCLE.
WE WHEN WE SUBMITTED THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET TO THE
DEPARTMENT FIND AT THOSE IN
OCTOBER.
TWENTY. EIGHT POINT SEVENTEEN.
AND WE DID NOT KNOW THE FULL
EXTENT OF OUR COST OBLIGATIONS A
BURDENS THAT TIME WE ARE FULLY
FUNDED FOR THE ON GOING COST IS
THE ONE TIME COSTS REPRESENT THE
CHALLENGE IN THIS ARE ASK.
I REQUEST.
THANK YOU.
WE DON'T.
OKAY.
THANK YOU OF THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IF YOU. NEXT AND FINAL ISSUES
DEBATE COMMISSION
.
OKAY PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR BEGAN
MARRY OUR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AS YOUR AGENDA NOTES THE MAYOR
VISION MAKES A NUMBER OF CHANGES
TO THE. APPROPRIATIONS AND IT
HAS HAPPENED TO NAY COMMISSION
AND MOST OF THOSE ARE LARGELY
CONCENTRATED AROUND.
ENROLLMENT IN CASE THAT WITHIN
THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM. THE MAYOR
VISION ALSO INCLUDES AN
ADJUSTMENT TO THE TRAILER BILL
PROPOSAL THAT WAS SUBMITTED WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. WITH
REGARD TO ASSOCIATE DEGREES FOR
TRANSFER AND THE MAXIMUM CAL
GRANT TUITION AWARD AT PRIVATE
NONPROFIT INSTITUTIONS. THE
ADJUSTMENT OF THAT PROPOSAL IS
THAT IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THE
EXPECTATION OF TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED STUDENTS ADMITTED HAS
BEEN LOWERED TO TWO THOUSAND.
IN NINETEEN TWENTY THERE STILL
AN EXPECTATION OF THREE THOUSAND
STUDENTS ACCEPTED HOWEVER IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THERE IS NOW
AN EXPECTATION THAT THIRTY FIVE
HUNDRED STUDENTS ARE ACCEPTED
AND THAT NOW SERVES AS THE NEW
BASS LINE MOVING FORWARD INTO
THE OUT YEARS.
GROWN BY THE PERCENTAGE CHANGE
IN TRANSFERS THE SECTOR AS A
WHOLE.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU LA IF.
THIS ISSUE ISN'T OUR ANALYSIS IF
YOU TURN TO PAGE THIRTY THREE
YOU CAN SEE THE SUMMARY OF ALL
FOUR OF MAY REVISION PROPOSALS
FOR THE SYDNEY COMMISSION.
I JUST WALK THROUGH ON THE FOR
ON THE FIRST ISSUE YOU KNOW WE
SAY ADOPT NAM. WAS BASED ON A
PRELIMINARY REVIEW A SINCE OUR
REVIEW WE DID.
TRADITIONAL THINGS WE HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS ON A FOR EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN COSTS FOR THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THAT GETS AND
CLARITY ON THAT SO WE WOULD LIKE
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
INDUSTRY ADMINISTRATION ON THAT.
OF THE TEN IF PROPOSAL WE DON'T
HAVE CONCERNS WITH.
THE OF CAL GRANT PROPOSAL FOR
THE THE PROPOSAL FOR THE
NONPROFIT CALTRANS.
I'M JUST JUST FOR OF ADDITIONAL
CLARITY I FIGURE SEVENTEEN ON
THAT SAME PAGE.
SUMMARIZES THE THE CHANGES THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING
TO MAKE TO THE EXPECTATIONS
REVIEW THESE CHANGES AS AS
FAIRLY MINOR OTHER CORPS OF THE.
PROPOSAL STONE PLACE AND WE
STILL HAVE FUNDAMENTAL CONCERNS
WITH FACTS
AND THIS PROPOSAL DOES NOT
ADDRESS OUR FUNDAMENTAL CONCERNS
AND WE CONTINUE TO KNOW THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION CAN YOU KNOW
DOESN'T DOESN'T HAVE.
.
A DATA ON ADMISSIONS I'D THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR FORCED OF
STUDENTS WITH AN ASSOCIATE
DEGREE FOR TRANSFERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE SELECTS A BASELINE
TO DETERMINE WHETHER. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR THE MAY
REVISION IS THE APPROPRIATE
EXPECTATIONS.
ON THE FINAL IF YOU FOR THE A
GENERAL FUND LOAN OF FOR OF C.
SAX I CASH FLOW.
WERE STILL A WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THAT AS WELL
THEY'VE COMMITTED TO GET US OF A
CASH FLOW ANALYSIS TO. IT SUCH
THAT FURTHER ARMS WERE STILL
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
ON THAT PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU TODAY COMMISSION
GOOD MORNING DAVID O'BRIEN OF
THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION A WITH REGARD TO THE
ITEMS INCLUDING THE MAY REVISION
WE HAVE NO CONCERNS WE CONTINUE
TO APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ONGOING
SUPPORT.
OF OUR STUDENTS AND OUR
FINANCIALLY PROGRAMS.
AND THE CONSERVATIVE ELIO HIS
REYES WE ARE WORKING WITH
FINANCE IN THE ALLEY ó TO
PROVIDE. THE INFORMATION THEY'VE
REQUESTED ON THOSE I'M AND THEN
YOUR AGENDA JUST DOES NOTE
BRIEFLY THAT.
THE COMMISSION DID ENDORSE SOME
ITEMS OUT OF THE RECENT CENTURY
FOUNDATION PART OF FINANCIALLY
CONSOLIDATION AND REFORM. THAT
UP OUR COMMISSIONERS HAVE
EXPRESSED INTEREST IN SEEING IN
THE BUDGET SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITHOUT THE
LEGISLATURE THE ADMINISTRATION
AND YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF ON
THOSE ITEMS.
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU.
NO QUESTIONS ON THESE ITEMS.
OKAY WITH THAT WE WILL PROCEEDS.
PUBLIC COMMENT.
READY.
I AND PLEASE TRY TO KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS TO ONE MINUTE OR LESS
ALRIGHT ALRIGHT THANK YOU.
.
ON. ALLEN ROTH DOWDEN FROM SEIU
LOCAL ONE THOUSAND WE'RE GOING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
ONLINE COLLEGE AND THANK
EVERYONE FOR ALL THE WORK TO
MAKE IT A MUCH BETTER PROPOSAL
AT THIS POINT. IN WERE ALSO
SUPPORTING IN THE MAY REVISION
THE APPORTIONMENT LANGUAGE FOR
APPRENTICE PROGRAMS WE THINK
AGAIN THIS MEETS MANY OF THE.
ORIGINAL ON A QUESTIONS THAT WE
HAD IN MORE FULLY IN SUPPORT OF
OF THAT NOW THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS SYLVIA
SOLELY SHAUN BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
WE REMAIN OPPOSED TO THE ONLINE
COLLEGE. A PROPOSAL WE ARE OUR
CONCERNS ARE IN LINE WITH THOSE
OF CF TEA AND THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WE THINK THERE'S AN
EXTRA EXISTING ONLINE COLLEGE
STRUCTURE IN PLACE LET'S. PUT
MORE FUNDING IN THAT DIRECTION
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
CHAIR MCCARTY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VOEPEL JAKE BREMNER WITH THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
COMMENTING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING
FORMULA PROPOSED IN THE MAY
REVISION WE'VE PROVIDED TO EACH
OF YOUR OFFICES A LETTER. CO
SIGNED BY TWENTY FIVE EQUITY
ORGANIZATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THAT WANT TO SEE THIS MOVE
FORWARD THIS YEAR THE MAY
REVISION REPRESENTS A LOT OF
PROGRESS IN INCORPORATING
FEEDBACK FROM EQUITY. ADVOCATES
AS WELL AS OTHER STAKEHOLDERS IN
THE SYSTEM AND WOULD JUST ASK IF
NOT NOW WHEN HOW MANY MORE
STUDENTS TO ENROLL IN THE SYSTEM
WITHOUT HAVING FISCAL POLICY
THAT INCENTIVIZE WITH ACCESS AS
WELL AS EQUITY AND SUCCESS.
I APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING LARA'S ABA CUBANS
WITH THE INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE
ACCESS AND SUCCESS OFTEN HONESTY
GUESTS WE ALONG WITH A
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENT FINANCIAL AID
ADMINISTRATORS ASSOCIATION THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE STUDENT SENATE
FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THE CALIFORNIA AS
COALITION CALIFORNIA COMPETES IN
THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY RESPECTFULLY URGE.
THE SUBCOMMITTEE TO ADOPT OUR
PROPOSAL FOR CONSOLIDATING THE
FULLTIME COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS.
OUR ALTERNATIVE WOULD HELP MORE
STUDENTS ATTEND FULL TIME AND
SHORE AYE. PER CREDIT GRANT
AMOUNTS ARE MORE EQUITABLY
DISTRIBUTED SO THAT OUR MOST
UNDERSERVED STUDENTS INCLUDING
AFRICAN AMERICAN AND LATINO
RECIPIENTS RECEIVE THE GREATEST
BENEFIT THAT WILL BETTER ENABLE
THEM TO SIXTY.
ADDITIONALLY WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO.
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR LONG
OVERDUE TECHNOLOGICAL UPGRADES
FOR FINANCIALLY OFFICES AND
FINALLY A COALITION OF MORE THAN
TWENTY ORGANIZATIONS SUPPORT
CEEFAX RECOMMENDATION TO
INCREASE THE CAL GRANT THE
ACCESS AWARD. THIS AWARD IS
CURRENTLY WORTH LESS THAN TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS HAD KEPT HIS
WITH INFLATION WOULD BE WORTH
FOUR TIMES THAT REGIONAL VALUE
SO I THINK YOU SUMMIT. THANK
YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS KURT CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
WHERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ON IN V.
ONLINE COLLEGE AND.
OUT WE ARE ALL SO SUPPORTIVE OF
THE MAY REVISION OF PROPOSALS
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S INCLUDED AS
YOU KNOW. TECHNOLOGY IS ONE OF
THE BEST FRIENDS OF UP PERSONS
WITH A DISABILITY SO WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO WORK CLOSELY WITH BUFFY
ADMINISTRATION IN THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. FOR
ENSURING THAT THERE ARE FULL
SERVICES AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES THAT ARE
EQUIVALENT TO. OF THE SERVICES
THAT WILL BE AVAILABLE IN THE
OTHER A HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN
CAMPUSES AND SO WE'VE AGREED ON
AND.
THAT PORTION IN THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE AND SUPPORT AS
WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MITCHELL BACK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
WE'RE PLEASED TO SEE THAT THEM A
REVISION INCLUDED. FIVE MILLION
GENERAL FUND.
INVESTMENT IN GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION HOWEVER WE WOULD URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO MODIFY THIS
PROPOSAL TO ENSURE THAT FORTY
MILLION OF THESE DOLLARS ARE
AVAILABLE.
TO THE UC TO MAKE THEIR BUDGET
BASED BUDGET HOLE FOR THAT PROP
FIFTY SIX FUNDS ARE FREED UP AND
AVAILABLE FOR STATEWIDE
ALLOCATION FOR. A GME PROGRAMS
AS THE VOTERS INTENDED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU TAMAR COMMENT REPRESS
ILLUSTRIOUS CALLS FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS ALSO THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION TEACHERS. AND THAT
THE CESSATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE COLLEGES OUT WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE ONLINE
COLLEGE A THIS PROPOSAL DOES NOT
PROVIDE THE DETAILS NECESSARY TO
UNDERSTAND THE NEED THAT IF THE
PHILS OR THAT IT WILL BE
SUCCESSFUL. UNDER THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING PROPOSAL HAS HAD NO
INPUT FROM MANY FOR THAT BAH
CLICK THEIR BARGAINING AGENT OR
ANY STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION AT
ALL.
THERE MANY CONFLICTS AND MANY
PROBLEMS THAT THAT IT WOULD HAVE
TO OVERCOME NONE OF THAT HAS
BEEN DISCUSSED.
THE CREEK LIMON OTHER PROGRAMS
I SHOULD BE DEVELOPED BY THE
ACADEMIC SENATE WISH HERE IS
NOT RIGHT NOW THERE'S ONLY
PROPOSED BY THE STATE CHANCELLOR
AND THE AND THE SAINT JOHN'S
OFFICE.
THEY HAVE PROPOSED A OF A
MEDICAL CODING A PROGRAM FOR
THIS COLLEGE.
CURRENTLY WITH A WE OFFER A
MEDICAL A COATING PROGRAM AT
THIS IN THIS RIVER COLLEGE SO.
OF THE PROPOSAL THAT IT WOULD
NOT CONFLICT WITH EXISTING
PROGRAMS.
THERE'S ALREADY DEMONSTRATE
THAT THERE'S A CONFLICT IN THIS
PROPOSAL.
A WILL ALSO A VERY MUCH REJECT
THE THE NEW FUNDING FORMULA
THERE'S A VERY SPECIFIC FOCUS ON
TRYING TO GET STUDENTS UP
THROUGH ITS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
WITHIN TWO YEARS. A THAT MEANS
THAT THEY ARE FULL TIME UP WE
ARE DIRECTING MORE FUNDS FOR
FULL TIME STUDENTS IF YOU TAKE A
LOOK AT THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF THAT
MEANS THAT THERE'S GONNA BE LESS
SUPPORT FOR REMEDIAL A WIN TERMS
OF REMEDIAL CLASSES WHICH. ARE
BEING CUT IF YOU TAKE A LOOK
ACROSS THE STATE RIGHT NOW THAT
MEANS LESS SUPPORT FOR.
LESS PREPARED STUDENTS LESS
SUPPORT FOR LOW INCOME STUDENTS
AND LESS PURPOSE US SUPPORT FOR
STUDENTS OF COLOR THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU ARE I'M
DAVID MANTLE WITH JEWISH VOICE
FOR PEACE REPRESENTING OUT
LUCENT BRAVELY BROAD COALITION
OF CIVIL RIGHTS. ORGANIZATIONS.
CONCERNED VERY MUCH WITH THE
KIND OF.
WITH BUT BIAS RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION RACISM SEXISM.
I SOME FOR BE ANOTHER PHENOMENON
THAT WE HAVE SEEN ON CAMPUS I'M
I'M HERE TO ADDRESS. ON THE ITEM
ON THE TOP OF PAGE NINE SMALL.
OF PROPOSAL TO GRANT FOR UC AND
CSU OFFER AND DEVISE TRAINING
WILL
WE'RE AWARE THAT A PER
THE ORGANIZATION HAS BEEN
LOBBYING HARD WITH THE
EXPECTATION THAT THAT IT WOULD.
ACTUALLY PROVIDE THAT TRAINING
THAT'S THAT IS THE ANTI
DEFAMATION LEAGUE.
AND I KNOW FROM PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE THAT SOMETIMES EVEN
IF IT'S NOT WRITTEN IN THE.
IN THE PROPOSAL.
THAT IT CAN BE DONE SOMETIMES
WITH THAT AS A DESIGN
SO I I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S THE
CASE
BUT OUR CONCERN IS THAT THE
PROVIDER OF THIS TRAINING.
NOT BE ITSELF A CHRONIC.
.
PRACTITIONER OF BIAS WHICH THIS
PARTICULAR ORGANIZATION HAS WHO
MAY HAVE. NOTICED THAT THAT WHEN
THERE WAS THE.
EPISODE SEVERAL WEEKS AGO IN
PHILADELPHIA. AT AT STARBUCKS.
IT WAS ORIGINALLY PROPOSED THAT
THEY PROVIDE.
TRAIN FOR STARBUCKS AND THEN
THEY WERE DEMOTED LEFT WHEN THEY
WERE SUCH INTO. A ITEM YOU HAVE
THAT.
SIXTY SACKETT ó I'M RIGHT AND
WE HAVE A BIG BIG HEART MIND AND
THAT KIND OF THIS FINISH WITH
WITH WITH MUCH YET ONCE AGAIN
WITH MY. MY SUGGESTION IS THAT
THAT. IN THAT THIS PROPOSAL BE
APPENDED TO.
INSIST THAT.
THAT THE PROCESS OF CHOOSING A
PROVIDER BOBBY A TRANSPARENT
PROCESS.
SELECTION INVOLVING A PUBLIC
REQUEST FOR PROPOSALS AND
IMPOTENT INPUT FROM THE BROAD
CAMPUS COMMUNITIES.
THAT WOULD BE AFFECTED BY IT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND I HAVE A ARM.
A MEMO ON THE SUBJECT WE'RE
TALKING HERE FOR DISTRIBUTION
THAT I'VE ALSO SENT
ELECTRONICALLY TO YOUR STAFF
AND.
I ADVISE BECAUSE A LOT OF LINKS
AND IT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ERIKA ROMERO BEHALF
THE ASSOCIATION OF INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES REPRESENTING THE
PRIVATE NOT FOR PROFIT WE
SUPPORT THAT MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL AROUND THE CAL GRANT.
AND THE EIGHTY CHILLING WHICH WE
THINK THE GOVERNOR AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOR
WORKING WITH US AND THE
LEGISLATURE FOR CONSISTENTLY
SUPPORTED OUR STUDENTS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
SYNDICATE STEEL BEHALF THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE'D LIKE TO.
THINK THAT CONSULTANTS ON THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE STRONG
ANALYSIS.
WE REMAIN STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
THE ONLINE COLLEGE IN FUNDING
FORMULA AND LIKE TO ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH THE CONCERNS
OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS. AND
RELATED TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL'S QUESTION ABOUT.
DUPLICATIVE COURSES WE'D LIKE
TO LINE OUR COMMENTS MEDINA
MARKKANEN RELATED TO OUR COURSES
ALREADY ON COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ARE EAST GIVING MEDICAL CODING
AS A COURSE.
AND.
ADDITIONALLY FAQ WOULD LIKE TO
NOTE THE ABSENCE OF FUNDING FOR
FACULTY AND STERN SUPPORT
SERVICES IN THE MAY REVISION.
WHICH WE BELIEVE IT'S CRITICAL
TO OUR SYSTEM.
WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE FUNDING
FOR THE C. ID I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE IT BE ONGOING WE'D ALSO LIKE
TO RECOMMEND THAT THE O. WE ARE
BE MOVED TO THE ACADEMIC
SENATE'S BUDGET AND LASTLY WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT AND
GRATITUDE. FOR THE FIVE MILLION
ALLOCATION FOR NEXT UP THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
CAN REALLY ROSEMARY WITH SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
WERE SUPPORT OF THE ON LINE
THREE COLLEGE PROPOSAL AND ARE
THANKFUL FOR THIS COMMITTEE. AND
ADMINISTRATION'S EFFORTS TO
INVOLVE THOSE SO THAT ADDRESSES
A NUMBER OF ISSUES WE DO I
ACKNOWLEDGE THE DEVIL'S IN THE
DETAILS AND WE HOPE TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH YOU. ON.
FURTHER EXPANDING THOSE ISSUES
OF COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AND
DIFFERENT PROTECTIONS BUT WE
NOTICED THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS.
OFFERING AS WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS GIVES A SHORT TERM
EDUCATION IN THE. NONPROFIT
PUBLIC EDUCATION BECAUSE WE ARE
WE HAVE SEVENTEEN MEMBERS IN
ALMOST EVERY SINGLE SEVENTY
LOCALS EVERY SINGLE ONE STANDS
TO BENEFIT FROM SHORT TERM
CERTIFICATES OR.
SKILLS THAT EDUCATION SO WE
URGE THAT YOU CONTINUE TO SEE
THIS PROPOSAL THROUGH AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
THINK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ALLEN HIGHLAND REPRESENTING NEXT
GEN AMERICA HERE SUPPORTING TO.
ITEMS FIRST THAT.
SUPPORTING THAT COMMAND COLLEGE
FUNDING FORMULA ALL DISTILLING
MY COMMENTS TO THE CALL AT
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
ON THOSE AND ALSO SUPPORTING THE
ONLINE COLLEGES. AND WE
SUPPORTED THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL SINCE JANUARY SUPPORT
THE MAY REVISIONS TO IT BUT WE
APPRECIATE.
.
CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS
REGARDING THEIR SHOWING OTHERS A
LOT OF DETAILS THAT STILL NEED
TO BE WORKED OUT THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS REBECCA RA SALAS
LOVELL AND I AM THE KEY FEES
NEXT APART NADER AT SANTA ROSA
JUNIOR COLLEGE.
I WANNA THINK THE GOVERNOR AND
ALL OF YOU IN YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND SUPPORTING FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR LPS NEXT THE
PROGRAMS PERTAINING TO FOSTER
YOUTH. AT CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THIS FUNDING INSURERS
CONTINUE PUTTING SUPPORT FOR
STUDENTS AND EMPLOYMENT FOR
CURRENT NEXT UP STAFF IN
JEOPARDY OF LOSING THEIR
POSITIONS AT THE END OF JUNE OR
IN THE YEAR AS A RESULT OF THE
NEXT ALLOCATION FORMULA. THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
HI MY NAME IS KAREN LOPEZ AND
THEN THE NEXT OF SPECIALIST FOR
THE NEXT STEP PROGRAM AT THE
CENTER IS A JUNIOR COLLEGE. I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU AND THE
GOVERNOR FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THE
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA.
OTHER COMMUTE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
NEXT TO PROGRAMS ANDSUPPORTING
FOSTER USE A AND THIS MONEY WILL
ALLOW US TO CONTINUE TO HIRE
STAFF TO HELP DEVELOP AND MAKE.
THE PROGRAM SUCCESSFUL WITHOUT
THIS ADDITIONAL FUNDING PROGRAMS
WILL BE LOSING STOP INCLUDING
MYSELF AT THE END OF JUNE THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING TO ROGER WAGNER
HERE ON BEHALF OF PROSECUTING
THE COLLEGE DISTRICT WHERE
COLLEGE ON THE NEXT DECADE IS
PROGRAM MANAGER. WILL LIKE TO
THINK THE CHEN.
THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS IN ALL
OF YOUR LEADERSHIP IN SUPPORT OF
THE FIVE MEN DOLLAR.
GRANT FOR NEXT AT COLLEGES
SENATE BUILT.
TWELVE PASS THAT HISPANIC THIS
TO TWENTY DISTRICTS WITHOUT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING SO WITH THAT
SUPPORTED THIS ADDITIONAL FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS WILL BE ABLE TO.
I RESPECTFULLY ACCOMMODATE THE
NEW DISTRICTS AS WELL AS
MAINTAIN STAFFING AND SERVICES
FOR ALL CURRENT FOSTER YOUTH
SERVING A DISTRICTS THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MISTER VOEPEL TO
MADDEN REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS WERE
APPRECIATIVE GOVERNOR INCLUDING
GOT FIFTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
AND GRADUATE DELUDE KITCHEN THE
MAY REVISE ALTHOUGH WE WERE
DISAPPOINTED TO SEE THAT HE
CONTINUES. TO TAKE FORTY MILLION
OTHER PROP FIFTY SIX DOLLARS
AWAY FROM THE UC'S BUDGET THAT'S
TAKING IT AWAY FROM FUNDING
PRIMARY CARE AND EMERGENCY
PHYSICIAN PRESIDENCY SLOTS.
I WERE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THIS
COMMITTEE'S SUPPORT IN TRYING TO
RESTORE THE PROFIT TO SIX FUNDS
FOR ITS INTENDED PURPOSES.
IF THE COMMITTEE DECIDE TO GO TO
A DIFFERENT DIRECTION WE WOULD
BE SUPPORTIVE OF THE CMA
PROPOSAL WHICH WE TO LOOK AT THE
FIFTY FIVE MILLION. CAR ABOUT
FORTY OF THAT TO BE USE AS.
AS BEEN INDICATED IN PROP FIFTY
SIX
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
BRIAN HOW THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS.
I WANT TO APPRECIATE THIS
COMMITTEE FOR A VERY DETAILED
HEARINGS ON BOTH PROPOSALS UP
FUNDING FORMULA AND ON MY
COLLEGE.
EVEN THE ARE DOT PARTISAN
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AS
YOU IS RECOMMENDING A REJECTION
OF THIS PROPOSAL. AYE AND ON THE
FUNDING FORMULA ARE THERE SO
MANY UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
THAT WE FACE SO I BET THAT CFT
RECALL ON YOU TO REJECT BOTH
PROPOSALS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING I'M RAMONA COLLINS
I AM A LIBRARIAN AT UC BERKELEY
AND WITH JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF A
NEED FOR MORE FUNDING WE AT THE
LIBRARY WOULD LIKE TO HAVE AT
LEAST ONE COPY OF EVERY REQUIRED
TEXTBOOK.
TO SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS AND TO
ALLEVIATE SOME OF THE FINANCIAL
BURDEN.
WE CAN'T AFFORD IT IT'S NOT IN
OUR BUDGET THINKING.
HELLO I'M JOHN RUN IN WITH THE
UC A F. T. THE UNION THAT
REPRESENTS LIBRARIANS LECTURES
THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA. I'M A
LECTURE AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
WHEN YOU DAVIS. MY FIRST COMMENT
IS ON ONLINE EDUCATION THIS IS
AT THIS POINT SORT OF A ZOMBIE
IDEA ONLINE EDUCATION IS A
REALLY BAD IDEA OR IF IT WERE TO
BE MADE A GOOD IDEA THAT'S GOING
TO BE MORE EXPENSIVE THAN JUST
HAVING BRICKS AND MORTARS.
OF BRICKS AND MORTAR SCHOOLS
THAT'S NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO I
WANT TO URGE OF. THE LEGISLATURE
TO SUPPORT FULL ON FUNDING FOR
THE OFFICE OF CALIFORNIA IN THE
MOST RECENTLY A FLOOR PROPOSES
BY THE GOVERNOR OF MANY THE
UNIVERSE UNIVERSITET OF FORMULAS
NEEDS REMAIN ON REMAIN
UNFULFILLED. AND I THINK THAT WE
NEED TO SUPPORT THE UNIVERSITY
AS AN ENGINE OF ECONOMIC GROWTH
AND AND PROSPERED FOR CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MY NAME'S AXLE BOARD
I'M A LIBRARIAN AT UC DAVIS.
I'M A FIFTH GENERATION
CALIFORNIAN AND FOUR GENERATIONS
OF MY FAMILY HAVE BENEFITTED
FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. I'M A WEST
SACRAMENTO A RESIDENT AND SO I'M
HONORED TO BE REPRESENTED BY.
MCGUCKIN MCCARTHY.
WE STAND IN AWE OPPOSITION TO
ONLINE EDUCATION I'VE PERSONALLY
BEEN INVOLVED IN THE
DEVELOPMENT.
OF ONLINE COURSES AT DAVIS IN
THEIR EXTRAORDINARILY EXPENSIVE.
TO GET UP AND GOING AND THEN TO
CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN.
WE ALSO URGE FULL FUNDING OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU.
THE CHAIRMAN BURST ON KEPT HE
MCCUE KEPT CAN ASSESS ITS ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
FOR ADULT EDUCATION IN
CALIFORNIA DON'T EDUCATION
ADMINISTRATORS ASSOCIATION. AND
WE APPRECIATE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSALS
RELATIVE TO ADULT EDUCATION AS
WELL AS INCREASING COLA HOWEVER
WE DO I URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
ALSO AND NOT CONSIDER INCREASING
THE FUNDING FOR ADULT EDUCATION.
AS IT'S BEEN STAGNANT CYCLE
LEVEL ONLY ADDRESS JUST THE COST
INCREASES ADDITIONALLY PROPOSED
ON THAT THE COMMITTEE CONSIDER
INCLUDE INCORPORATING IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION METRICS AS PART OF.
THE ADULT EDUCATION BLOCK GRANT
FRAMEWORK AND FINALLY ON SUPPORT
SOUNDING YOU CHANGE IN THE TERM
GRANT IN THE ADULT THAT BLOCK
GRANT CONSISTENT WITH THE
SENATE'S PROPOSAL INACTION THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
CHEN MCCARTY MEMBERS WE
APPRECIATE YOUR STAMINA WITH
LARRY PLEASE HEAR FROM THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEE WE
REPRESENT THE FOUR HUNDRED FORTY
ONE TRUSTEES IN THE CHANCELLOR'S
IN THE PRESIDENT'S. ARM WE
PARTNER WITH THE ACT OF A
STATEWIDE ACADEMIC SENATE FOR
THE.
WE ARE SIX MILLION DOLLARS AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THAT.
IN THAT ALSO FOR THE FINANCIAL
AID TECHNOLOGY MODERNIZATION.
WE PASSED A BE NINETEEN. BUT WE
HAVE ANTIQUATED SYSTEMS FOR
FINANCIAL AID SO THIS MONEY THAT
THIRTEEN POINT FIVE MILLIN IN
THE FIVE MILLION WILL REALLY
HELP YOU I INCREASE THE
INSTITUTIONAL CAPACITY TO GET
THE MONEY INTO THE HANDS OF THE
STUDENTS.
WHICH IS SORELY NEEDED FINALLY
ON THE ARE ON THE FUNDING
FORMULA WE WOULD WE WOULD ASK
THAT.
.
CAPACITY BE INCREASED FOR THE
INSTITUTIONS BY CONTINUOUSLY
APPROPRIATING A COLA.
A TWO YEAR HOLD HARMLESS IS IS
MUCH BETTER. WE WOULD HOPE THAT
WOULD HAVE HIGHER BASE AND AND
COLA LEVEL. AND THEN ALSO I AM.
A THREE YEAR AVERAGE IS A GREAT
IMPROVEMENT INCREASED AT HELP US
WITH PLANNING AND AND STABILITY.
WE WOULD ASK THOUGH FOR A
PROGRESSIVE PHASE AND AS THE C.
E. O. WORK GROUP ARE YOU ASKED
FOR IN THEIR PROPOSAL AND
FINALLY THAT THE ONE HUNDRED
FOUR MILLION OF ONE TIME MONEY.
BE CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATE
BEYOND ONGOING SOME THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS COLORS
GOMEZ EMCEED AT COUPLE OF MONA
NAM I SENT TO THE COMMITTEE THAT
LOOKING AT THE MAY REVISE.
WE URGE THE COMMITTEE TO FULLY
FUND THE CSU TWENTY SIXTY THREE
MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST. THE
EXPANDED FUNDING WOULD ALLOW
PUTTING GROWTH AND ACCESS TO
ACADEMIC AND OTHER WHICH IS ON
CAMPUS SO THINK EVERYTIME.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JUAN
GARCIA AND I'M ALSO STUDENT A
COUPLE OF MINUTES.
LOOK AT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
FRANKLY WE ARE RATHER
DISAPPOINTED AND NOT JUST IT
THIS YEAR BEEN YEARS PRIOR.
WE BELIEVE IT'S TIME THAT OUR
PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS ARE SO ARE
FUNDED.
AS MUCH AS THEY NEED
SPECIFICALLY TO SEE IF YOU WE
ARE ASKING FOR THE FULL TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WE NEED TO SERVE
STUDENTS TO THE BEST OF OUR
ABILITY.
BUT IT.
HAVE MY NAME IS ANNA GREENBERG
I'M ALSO STUDENT HELP LIKE MONA
MEMBER OF THE CSSA.
I'M HERE TODAY TO STAND IN
SUPPORT OF A FULLY FUNDED CSU OF
WE ARE VERY DISAPPOINTED THE
GOVERNOR FOR NOT SEEING THE
POTENTIAL THAT STUDENTS IN
HIGHER EDUCATION HOW FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SO WE'RE
HERE TODAY TO STAND SUPPORT OF
THE FULLY FUNDED CSU BUDGET OF
TWO HUNDRED SIXTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS. THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WHICH I
SURPRISED THAT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION.
HAPPY ON THE ONLINE COLLEGE
ISSUE WE ARE MOVING TOWARDS
SUPPORT. PENDING VERIFICATION ON
ALL OF THE LANGUAGE THAT'S BEEN
PUT OUT. OF WE WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT THE. EMPLOYEES WHO WORK AND
THAT'S UNDER ERA WHICH I BELIEVE
HAS BEEN ADOPTED AND THAT THERE
BE A VOICE FOR TO CLASSIFY
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES TO BE PART OF
DEVELOPMENT AND. CREATION OF
THIS PROGRAM ON MONDAY OF THE
TEAM OF THE COMMISSION OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT WOULD PUT THIS
TOGETHER. AND ULTIMATELY WOULD
LOVE TO HAVE MORE FOCUS ON THE
PUBLIC SECTOR EMPLOYEES WHO ARE
DEAD NOT STRANDED WORKERS PER SE
BUT TO FOLKS WHO. COULD BENEFIT
FROM DE SOTO
ONE TIME TYPE OF LICENSE A
TICKET THAT THEY WOULD UPGRADE
THEIR SKILLS FOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI MY NAME IS ATHENA GARCIA GONE
AND I AM A STUDENT AT CAL POLY
POMONA I AM HERE WITH MY PEERS
TODAY TO ADVOCATE FOR FULLY
FUNDED CSU WE ARE I AM VERY
DISAPPOINTED IN THE.
BUDGET REVISE AND WE WE ARE
COMING HERE TO REQUEST FOR THE A
TWO HUNDRED SIXTY THREE MILLION
THAT WE STILL NEED.
THE CHANCELLOR HAS.
.
A HEATER NEEDS AND LISTEN TO US
IN TERMS OF NOT INCREASING
TUITION AND NOW IT'S IN THE
HANDS OF THE STATE. ARMS I'M
HERE TO ASK YOU TO PLEASE ARM
ADVOCATE FOR THE CS YES WELL AND
TO FULLY FUND THE CSU. INTO.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS CARLA
CAMANCHE HELLO I AM A FIRST
GENERATION SOON AT CSU CHICO
MASO DR RECIPIENT MEANING THAT I
DON'T QUALIFY FOR FEDERALLY I
RELY SOLELY ON.
UNIVERSITY AND STATE I'M
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO BE ABLE
TO ACQUIRE MY.
HIGHER EDUCATION AND MY SISTER
ALSO.
IS IN THE SAME POSITION WE BOTH
ATENCIO CIOS. ARM I'M HERE TO.
IN A WAY YES THANK YOU GOVERNOR
BROWN FOR THE NINETY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS BUT ALSO TO EXPRESS MY
SINCE.
POINT MAN.
THE MERE.
OR IS A GOVERNOR BROWN HAS GIVEN
THE CSCO IT IS NOT ENOUGH WE
EDUCATE NEARLY HALF A MILLION
STUDENTS AND WERE NOT RECEIVING
ADEQUATE FUNDING TO NOT ONLY BE
ABLE TO AT LEAST SUSTAIN NOT.
BUT TO BE ABLE TO EXPAND THAT ON
HIGHER EDUCATION IS AN
INVESTMENT.
AND IT'S IN THE POT IT'S A
POSITIVE INVESTMENT FOR
CALIFORNIA ALL OF THE RESEARCH
POINTS TO IT SOME CUTE URGE
GOVERNOR BROWN TO PLEASE PROVIDE
US WITH A TWO HUNDRED SIXTY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS WHICH IS.
AS HAS BEEN STATED BEFORE REALLY
A MODEST ASKING FOR HOW MUCH
WORK THE CSU DOES THINK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS OUT OF LIBERTY AND
I'M A STUDENT AT.
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
NORTHRIDGE I'M IN JUST FOUR DAYS
OF BEING ALUMNI OF CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY NORTHRIDGE I'M
I'M ALSO HERE TO ASK FOR A FULLY
FUNDED CSU. THE GOVERNOR'S.
LOOK OF REFUSAL TO GIVE US THAT
TWO AND SIXTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WE NEED HUDSON
REALLY NEGATIVE EFFECTS ON OUR
SYSTEM. AND START OFF IT'S IT'S
YOU IDEA TO NORTHRIDGE I SET OFF
AT A COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
I'M IF I WERE TO APPLY FOR
TRANSFER TODAY WOULD BE REJECTED
ALONG WITH.
MANY OTHER STUDENTS WHO
REJECTED EVERY YEAR AND NOT.
REJECTION AND NOT NOT BEING
ALLOWED INTO UNIVERSITY TO SPITE
BEING QUALIFIED IS DIRECTLY
CAUSED BY THE STATE CONTINUING
TO DIVEST FROM OUR SYSTEM AND
NOT PRIORITIZE HIGHER EDUCATION.
HI MY NAME IS GUSTAVO OKAY HOUSE
I'M A STUDENT TO A COUPLE OF
MONA AND I'M HERE TO EXPRESS MY
DISAPPOINTMENT AND THE
GOVERNOR'S NINETY TWO POINT ONE
MILLION.
BUDGET ALLOCATION.
.
I'M.
HISPANIC AND I.
BENEFITTED FROM A THE CONDUIT
THAT.
.
CAPITAL EQUIPMENT PROVIDED TO
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY.
.
FROM MY CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM
PEOPLE ON CAMPUS PEOPLE ARE
BEING TURNED AWAY.
FROM GETTING.
.
INTO CAPPADONNA AND THEM I JUST
WANT TO SEE THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS THAT ARE LIKE ME OF NOT
BEING ABLE TO HAVE AN ACCESS TO
QUALITY AFFORDABLE EDUCATION
THANK YOU.
HI MARY DOLAN WITH CAL STATE
STUDENT ASSOCIATION AS OUR
STUDENTS HAVE ALREADY MENTIONED
THE NINETY TWO MILLION DOLLARS
AT THE GOVERNOR HAS OUT
ALLOCATED TO THIS YES YOU FALL
SHORT OF OBLIGATED. COSTS AND
MILLION SHORT OF FEE OUT FULL
TWO HUNDRED SIXTY THREE MILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET ASSET THIS YES YOU
PUT FORWARD. AT A TIME WHEN OUR
STUDENTS ARE ALREADY STRUGGLING
WITH EXTREMELY HIGH COST TO
ATTEND TO CREATING MAJOR.
BASIC NEEDS PROBLEMS.
WE WILL ADDITIONALLY ASK FOR
FOURTEEN MILLION TO FIND AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR WHICH
SEEKS TO PROVIDE HOUSING FOR OUR
NEARLY ELEVEN PERCENT OF
HOMELESS STUDENTS THINK IT.
HI MY NAME IS SAGE I'M A STUDENT
FROM UC DAVIS AND I AM FROM
SACRAMENTO I'M HERE REPRESENTING
RICE CALIFORNIA WHERE A
COALITION OF STUDENTS FIGHTING
FOR HIGHER EDUCATION FUNDING.
AND WHILE I'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
GRATITUDE FOR THE LIMITED
FUNDING THAT WAS ALLOCATED TO
THE UC AND CSU. IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET OUR PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES ARE STILL VERY FAR
FROM ADEQUATELY FUNDED. I'M YOUR
SUPPORT IS CRUCIAL TO ENSURING
THAT HIGHER EDUCATION STATES
ACCESSIBLE TO ANY AND EVERY
BRIGHT YOUNG MIND WOULD LIKE TO
ATTEND COLLEGE SO THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING. THIS AND CONSERVING
THE TEN THOUSAND STUDENTS
SUPPORTERS WHO'VE ALREADY CALLED
PETITIONS AND WILL CONTINUE TO
LOBBY ON THIS ISSUE PLEASE FULLY
FUND THE UC AND CSU THANK YOU.
HI I'M JEFFREY MICHAELS I TEACH
ENGLISH I'M THE PRESIDENT OF A
FACT ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE INDEPENDENCE
REPRESENTING THOUSANDS OF
FACULTY.
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON
THE COMMENTS THAT WE'VE HEARD
REALLY HOPING THAT THE COMMITTEE
AND THE LEGISLATURE. WILL BE
ABLE TO STAND UP TO THESE
PROPOSALS ON THAT OUR SYSTEM OF
CHECKS AND BALANCES WORK EVERY
FACULTY GROUP IN THE STATE
OPPOSES THE ONLINE COLLEGE OF
COURSE IT'S A BAD IDEA. WE CAN
DO IT BETTER AND CHEAPER USING
OUR EXISTING STRUCTURES THE NEW
FUNDING FORMULA IS A TERRIBLE
MISTAKE PERFORMANCE SPACE
FUNDING DOESN'T WORK.
PLEASE REMEMBER AS YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT ALTERNATIVES THAT
WERE.
ALL OF OUR EDUCATION REFORMS.
ARE STRUGGLING BECAUSE WE LACK
THE CAPACITY FOR INSTITUTIONAL
CHANGE WHICH MEANS THAT WE LACK
THE NUMBER OF FULL TIME FACULTY
THAT WE NEED TO DO THE WORK WE
NEED FULLY PROFESSIONAL ICE PART
TIME FACULTY WITH OFFICE HOURS
AND FAIR PAY. AND WE NEED MORE
FULL TIME FACULTY AND THAT'S GOT
TO BE OUR PRIORITY BEFORE WE
THINK OF SWEEPING CHANGES TO THE
SYSTEM THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS CAROLYN SIEGEL
SAYING I'M HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE UC STUDENT ASSOCIATION AS
WELL AS THE ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE NEARLY
THIRTY THOUSAND STUDENTS AT UC
SAN DIEGO.
AND I'M HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT A
FULLY FUNDED CSU AND YOU SEE.
WE'VE COME FOR YOU MULTIPLE
TIMES SINCE JANUARY AND THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WAS
DISAPPOINTING IT FAILS STUDENTS
AND IT FAILS THE FUTURE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE DESERVE TO HAVE HOUSING BASIC
NEED SECURITY AND AN AFFORDABLE
EDUCATION WE DESERVE SUSTAINABLE
FUNDING IT'S REALLY TIME TO
INVEST IN THE FUTURE OF
CALIFORNIA. PLEASE FUND THE UC
AND CSU.
THANK YOU.
HELLO OF MY NAME IS KRISTEN
SEWER AND I'M A FOURTH YEAR
STUDENT AT UC SANTA BARBARA WELL
IT'S GREAT TO SEE INCREASED
FUNDING FOR.
THE UC'S DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
NEEDS WE NEED ADDITIONAL FUNDING
TO ADDRESS OVER IN ROME AND THE
BURDENSOME COSTS OF PURSUING
HIGHER EDUCATION EVEN AT A
PUBLIC INSTITUTION.
STUDENTS FACULTY AND STAFF COME
TO SACRAMENTO YEAR AFTER YEAR TO
FIGHT FOR THE FUNDING THAT WE
DESERVE ONE AS A LEGISLATURE
GOING TO SEE HIGHER EDUCATION AS
A WORTHY INVESTMENT. ONE IS A
LEGISLATURE GOING TO SEE
STUDENTS AS A WORTHY INVESTMENT.
OF WHEN IS THE LEGISLATURE GOING
SEE HIGHER EDUCATION OF THE
PUBLIC GOOD PLEASE FULLY COMING
HE SAID THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU CHAIRMAN MCCARTY
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE MY
NAME AS YOU LAY ON THE
VIETNAMESE AMERICAN ALSO THE
FIRST MY FAMILY TO ATTEND
UNIVERSITY.
I STARTED OUT SIERRA COLLEGE
WAS JUST COMMITTEE COLLEGES
OUTSIDE SACRAMENTO AND THEN
TRANSFERRED TO THE UC SANTA
BARBARA AND I'LL PROBABLY
SERVICE STUDENT BODY PRESIDENT.
OF PROTECT RECOGNIZE IMPORTS OF
COMBATING ENVIRONMENT OF
DISINVESTMENT FROM HIGHER
EDUCATION BOTH THE STATE AND
FEDERAL LEVEL.
THIS IS THE CENTRAL FRONT IS
KEEPING COSTS WERE TENANTS FROM
BALLOONING BUT FOR FURTHER
INVESTMENTS INTO STUDENTS.
WHAT I MEAN BY INVESTMENT
INVESTING IN MENTAL HEALTH
RESOURCES INVESTING CAREER
ADVANCEMENT INVESTING FACILITIES
DESIGNED TO ENRICH THE ACADEMIC
EXPERIENCE? AND INVESTING IN
MORE FACULTY TO OFFER MORE
COURSE OFFERINGS.
ALL STUDENTS SHOULD SUCCEED
WITHOUT ANOTHER STUDENT LOSING
OUT DUE TO A LACK OF RESOURCES.
STUDENTS SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
COMPETE AGAINST EACH OTHER FOR
SPOTS IN THE CLASSROOM FOR
APPOINTMENT TIMES OF AN ACADEMIC
ARTS PSYCHOLOGICAL COUNSELOR OR
FOR HOUSING SPOTS.
I DON'T I AM GRATEFUL THAT SOME
MONIES WERE ALLOCATED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S REVISE IT FELL SHORT
OF OUR CONSERVE ABOUT FOR FULLY
FUNDED YOU.
THIS BUDGET SIGNIFIES HIGHER
EDUCATION IS NOT A PRIORITY
I ASK THAT WE CONTINUE TO PUSH
FOR FULLY FUNDED YOU SEE TO
INVESTING CURRENT AND FUTURE
STUDENTS.
THROUGH ARE THE BACKBONES OF
WHAT MAKES CALIFORNIA THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS NIKKI THE LOOK I'M
A STUDENT AT UC IRVINE THEY ALSO
REPRESENT THE UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION AS THEIR GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS CHAIR BUT THE MOST.
CORPORAL I'M GLAD TO PLAY IS
BEING A RESIDENT ADVISER TO
SIXTY A AMAZING FRESHMAN AT UC
IRVINE AND THEY'RE REALLY THE
REASON WHY I'M HERE TODAY. FROM
THE BEGINNING OF SUMMER I'VE
SEEN HOW A LACK OF FUNDING TO
THE STUDENTS AFFECT THEM.
MY OF MY DORMITORY WENT FROM A
TRIPLE TWO O'CLOCK TO ACCOUNT
FOR IT WILL MAKE GROWTH.
AND I'M SO THANKFUL THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S MAYBE YOU GUYS
ACCOUNTS FOR THE DISCRETIONARY
FUNDING. FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BUT UNFORTUNATELY IT
DOES NOT TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE
OTHER ELEMENTS OF OUR BUDGET US
THAT WHAT TO ADDRESS STUDENT
NEEDS.
THIS INCLUDES TO ADDRESS THE
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO
ADDRESS THE IMPACTS OF
ENROLLMENT GROWTH TEN MILLION TO
ACCOUNT FOR THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
TO TWENTY NINETEEN M. OR WOMAN
GROWTH AND SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLARS. IN LIEU OF A TUITION
INCIDENT A SERVICE INCREASE FOR
THE NEXT SCHOOL YEAR.
I HAVE A RESIDENT WHO IS ONE OF
THE FEW FEMALES ATTEMPTING TO.
BE AN ENGINEER SHE'S AN
ENGINEERING MAJOR SHE ONLY HAS
FIVE OTHER PEOPLE'S ON HER
BECAUSE.
AND.
JUST BEING A FEMALE IN HER CLASS
ALONE IS A CHALLENGE THE FACT
THAT ON TOP OF THAT SHE HOUSE
TO.
ACCOUNT FOR FIGURING OUT HOW TO
PAY FOR TUITION HOW SHE'S GOING
TO SPEND THE SUMMER.
WRITING YOU KNOW STAYING UP BUT
IN NIGHTS WITH ME ON FACEBOOK
PAGES FIGHTING JOHNSON
INTERNSHIP SO SHE CAN PAY FOR
TUITION FOR THE NEXT SCHOOL
YEAR.
THESE ARE ALL THINGS THAT AFFECT
HER AND CHARLIE TRUE TO.
TO REACH OUR DREAMS OF BECOMING
AN ENGINEER AND ALTHOUGH I'M
GRADUATING THIS YEAR I REALLY
SEE THE IMPACT IMPACT OF ALL THE
CHOICES YOU MAKE HERE RIGHT NOW
AND I HOPE YOU TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT.
HER STORY THE MANY STORIES OF
THE STUDENTS HAVE COME BEFORE
YOU THINK IF YOU.
DALE XIN SAKE WITH ASSOCIATION
AMERICAN PUBLISHERS OF SPEAKING
ON THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES OPEN
EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES.
APPROPRIATION OF SIX MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME FUNDING. ON
IN ADDITION TO THE ALLOCATION OF
FUNDS A WE'D LIKE TO SEE
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT LANGUAGE. A
REQUEST TO THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE TO REVIEW HOW
THE FUNDS ARE USED AN EXPANDED
AND.
YOU KNOW TO WHAT EXTENT
STUDENTS TO USE THESE RESOURCES
AND CLUSTER.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHEN MCCARTY MANY
RODRIGUEZ ON THE HEALTH
EDUCATION TRUSTS WEST UNION
SUPPORTED STUDENT CENTER FUNDING
FORMULA. OF WE'RE GLAD THAT THE
MAY REVISE CONTINUES TO
HIGHLIGHT THE NEED TO.
CHANGE ARE FUNNY FOR MEDICAL
CARD SYSTEM THE PROPOSAL WAS
IMPROVE WITH A LOT OF THE KEY
REVISIONS AT DEPARTMENT FINANCE
ARE COVERED EARLIER TODAY. ITEM
WE ASK THAT YOU CONSIDER THIS.
FRAMEWORK MOVING FORWARD AND
THAT.
WE REALLY PRIORITIZE EQUITY WITH
ANY NEW REVENUE CREATED THANK
YOU.
BUT THEN I SEE ALREADY. THAT
IT'S FOR.
I'M NINE.
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
YOUTH AND A SPIRIT FOSTER CARE
SERVICES ARE BOTH IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE NEXT UP FOSTER
CARE PROPOSAL SO THAT'S FOR
SUPPORT FOR THAT THANK YOU OKAY.
PROBLEM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY WITH THAT WE ARE
ADJOURNED